Down in the basement It's cheap Hey guys, it's Joel And thank you for listening To the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast This will be the last part, Part four of our kind of talking about Some of the technical parts of health care
在地下室里，这很便宜。嘿，伙计们，我是乔尔。感谢你们收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。这将是最后一部分，即第四部分，我们讨论关于医疗保健的一些技术性问题。
That may not be interesting to everybody, but this is the last one, which covers some of the economic stuff. You know, the first two were on the DSM, you know, looking at one disorder in the DSM and then a deeper dive into some of the history of the kind of, the kind of contradictory assumptions, I think, are in the document and why they won't be leaving
这可能对每个人来说都不那么有趣，但这是最后一部分，涵盖了一些经济方面的内容。你知道，前两部分是关于 DSM 的，你知道，审视 DSM 中的一种疾病，然后深入探讨该文件中所包含的一些矛盾假设的历史，以及为什么除非系统发生相当大的变化，否则它们不会很快消失。
anytime soon unless the system changes quite a bit. So this one is on some of the regulatory aspects that limit innovation and drive up the cost of health care, especially psychotherapy, which is my area of practice. So, you know, if you hang around therapy, watercoolers, online forums like the, you know, clinical directors, Facebook group or the, um, private practice, you know, subreddit or something, you see all over again, you know, people start asking, you know, like, why are we the ones providing care while the system collapses and we have all of this, uh, our rates get driven down, you know, like I get, uh, network with a, uh, insurer and then, uh, I'm already, you know, taking a, uh, hit to be a network
所以这一部分是关于一些限制创新并推高医疗保健成本的监管方面，特别是心理治疗，这是我的执业领域。所以，你知道，如果你经常在治疗、饮水机旁、在线论坛（比如临床主任 Facebook 群组，或者私人执业 subreddit 之类的）闲逛，你会一次又一次地看到人们开始问，你知道，比如，为什么在系统崩溃时是我们提供护理，而我们所有的费率都被压低了，你知道，比如我与一家保险公司联网，然后，我已经，你知道，为了联网而遭受了损失，
and take an insurance remit and then I get contacted by multi-plan and they say, hey, if you want that Blue Cross Blue Shield remit like in the next four weeks instead of longer, why don't you just go ahead and take half and then you'll just get half as much? And then that way we'll process the paperwork more timely. Or you get contacted by a patient who thinks that they have Blue Cross and they type the information in, but it really is an insurance company where one of these little scam companies went to their, you know, uh,
并接受保险汇款，然后我被 MultiPlan 联系，他们说，嘿，如果你想要那张蓝十字蓝盾（Blue Cross Blue Shield）的汇款单在接下来的四周内到账，而不是更长时间，为什么你不直接接受一半，然后你只会得到一半的钱？这样我们处理文书工作会更及时。或者你被一个认为自己有蓝十字保险的病人联系，他们输入了信息，但实际上这是一家保险公司，其中一家小型诈骗公司找到了他们的，你知道，
group and said, hey, we'll just manage the mental health portion. And it'll be exactly like Blue Shield. It's just that you get a little bit of money back and like it's weird more efficient. And then it turns out that what they're going to do, what's just like Blue Cross Blue Shield is that when you go to a Blue Cross Blue
团体并说，嘿，我们只管理心理健康部分。它会和蓝盾完全一样。只是你会拿回一点钱，而且它更有效率。结果发现他们要做的事情，就像蓝十字蓝盾一样，当你去蓝十字蓝盾治疗师那里时，他们会打电话说，嘿，病人并没有真正的蓝十字蓝盾保险。但与其支付 250 美元或，你知道，保险汇款费率，为什么我们不给你，呃，60 美元。
Shield therapist, they call them and say, hey, the patient doesn't really have Blue Cross Blue Shield. But instead of 250 or, you know, the insurance remit rate, why don't we give you, uh, 60 bucks.
嗯，这行得通吗？如果不，我们将告诉病人你不配合。然后他们将不得不去找另一位提供者。而你已经和那个认为自己有蓝十字保险的人谈了三场，因为该计划被欺诈性地宣传为和蓝十字一模一样。
Um, does that work? And if not, we're going to tell the patient that you wouldn't play ball. And then they're going to have to go to another provider. And you're already three sets. and with the person who thought that they had Blue Cross because the plan was fraudulently advertised as being just like Blue Cross.
我希望蓝十字能去追究那些家伙的责任，既然我们在谈论这个。我不知道他们为什么不这样做，因为他们一直在非法营销。每次我从她那里听到消息时，我都会告诉他们的临床主任，但他们并没有改变他们的做法。我不会提到那家公司的名字，但如果你住在伯明翰，你可能能猜出来。如果你在谷歌上搜索伯明翰和另外两个词。但这是一个合乎逻辑的问题，对吧？
I wish Blue Cross would go after those guys while we're talking about it. I don't know why they don't because they market illegally all the time. And I tell their clinical director every time I hear from her and they have not changed their practices. I won't mention the name of the company, but you could probably figure it out if you live in Birmingham. And you Google Birmingham in two other words. But it's a logical question, right?
比如，如果治疗师如此重要，为什么他们赚得不多？如果一个治疗师是 EMDR 专家，他们每小时赚 300 美元，这看起来相当不错。我每小时赚不到 300 美元。你并没有真正看到其中包含的所有成本，我甚至不打算详细说明职业责任保险，以及那 300 美元被瓜分的所有方式。一小时的治疗并不是真正的一小时治疗。
Like why don't therapists, if they're so important, make more? and then if a therapist is a EMDR specialist and they make $300 an hour, that looks pretty good. I don't make $300 an hour. You don't really see all the costs that are built into that, which I'm not even really going to go through professional liability insurance and just like all the ways that that $300 is cut up. An hour of therapy is not really an hour of therapy.
还需要一小时来记录，通常还需要 30 分钟来计划和审查。但是，是的，这是一个有意义的问题。所以，你知道，汽车工人组建工会，教师组建工会，护士有工会。那么为什么没有像治疗师工会那样的组织，让州内或全国所有的治疗师都可以加入并说，嘿，这就是我们工作的目标，你需要从你的金库中找到钱来支付它。这样它就不会从病人的口袋里掏出来，也不会从我的生活方式中掏出来。你知道，我们大多数人都足够聪明，可以做其他能让我们赚更多钱的事情。大多数优秀的治疗师都是如此。答案是，你知道，那些结构感觉是一样的。
It takes another hour to chart and usually about 30 minutes to plan and review. But, yeah, it's a question that makes sense. So, you know, auto workers form unions, teachers, fill unions, nurses, have unions. So why are they not like a therapist union that all of the therapists in the state can go to and or the country and say, hey, this is what we're working for and you need to find it in your coffers to pay for it. So it's not coming out of the patient's pocket. And it's not coming out of my lifestyle. You know, most of us are smart enough to do something else that would make us more money. Most good therapists are. And the answer is that, you know, those structures feel the same.
但治疗师大多由一两个组织支付薪水，但由于某种原因，我们监管的方式使他们无法组建工会。这只是在审视医疗保健。我实际上并不是在倡导建立治疗师工会，文章中的原因会清楚地表明这是不可能的。但这确实是你考虑的事情。
but therapists are mostly paid by one or two organizations, but for some reason, the way we regulate, they're not able to form a union. This is just kind of examining health care. I'm not actually advocating for a therapy union and for reasons in the article, it'll be clear that that's not possible. But it is something that you think about.
所以这不是关于支持或反对工会的政治问题。这只是在审视我们用不同的名字称呼同一件事，用一个名字是非法的，用另一个名字是合法的，所以这是一个奇怪的监管环境。治疗师不能成立工会的真正原因，你知道，可以追溯到石油大亨和铁路巨头的时代。所以你有像《谢尔曼反托拉斯法》这样的法律，我认为它甚至在 1900 年之前，可能就在那之前，但就在那个时候。它的设计目的是让像标准石油公司这样的巨头不能串通定价并破坏自由市场。
So this is not a political thing about pro-con unions. It's just looking at the way that we call the same thing by different names and illegal by one name, legal by another, So it's a weird regulatory environment. And the real reason that therapists can't unionize, you know, it goes back to the era of oil barons and railroad tycoons. So you have like the Sherman Antitrust Act, which I think is before 1900 even, probably just before, but around then. And it's designed so that giant companies like standard oil can't collude to price fix and destroy the free market.
因为如果你记得茶壶山丑闻（Teapot Dome scandal），并且你知道历史书中那部分内容（大多数人不知道），标准石油公司会以低于实际生产成本的价格出售石油，这样他们就会亏损，人们会从标准石油公司购买石油，这会使所有无法承受相当于当时数百万美元损失的人破产，然后他们会抬高价格并翻倍，没有人与他们竞争，你知道，人们看到这一点觉得很糟糕，嗯，我们现在喜欢垄断，我的意思是，亚马逊的竞争对手是谁？我真的想不出一个。所以这并没有被大量使用，但相信我，如果治疗师成立了工会，
Because what standard oil would do if you remember the T. pot dome scandal and you know that part of your history book which most people don't was they would go in and they would sell oil cheaper than it actually cost to make it so they would lose money and people would buy the oil from standard and it would put everybody who couldn't eat you know what was the equivalent of millions of dollars of losses at the time out of business and then they would jack it up and double the price and no one was competing with them which you know people saw that looked bad um we like monopolies now i mean what's a competitor to amazon i can't really think of one. So this isn't used a whole lot, but believe you me, if therapists unionized,
它就会被使用。所以这项法律是对真正滥用行为的回应，那些基本上试图垄断并变得，你知道，脱离国家，但成为全国每个人或很大一部分人所需要的某种东西的唯一提供者的公司。所以这是一项好法律。我的意思是，我支持《谢尔曼反托拉斯法》。但问题在于，你知道，在联邦政府眼中，私人执业治疗师不是工人，因为我们不是被同一个人雇佣的，尽管我们通常由同一个，你知道，保险实体支付薪水。我们只是企业。我是一家有限责任公司（LLC）。我与 Taproot 签约。你知道，我收入的百分比用于维持我的集体运营，就像那里经营的每一位其他治疗师一样。我们都有相同的费率。而且，
it would be used. So this law was a response to the genuine abuses, the companies that were basically trying to have a monopoly and become, you know, separate from the state, but the sole provider of something that everyone in the country needed or a large portion. And so it's a good law. I mean, I support the Sherman Antitrust Act. But here's the catch, you know, in the eyes of federal government, a private practice therapist is not a worker because we're not employed by the same person, even though we're usually paid by the same, you know, insurance entity. We're just a business. I'm an LLC. I contract with Taproot. You know, a percentage of my income goes back to make my collective run, just like every other therapist that runs there. We all have the same rate. And,
你知道，如果你是一个在转租办公室里努力支付租金的个体从业者，在车里哭泣和在办公桌前吃午饭之间看客户，你知道，在浴缸里前后摇晃，咬着毛巾哭泣，你知道，法律把你视为微型公司的首席执行官。所以你被归类为 1099 独立承包商，你知道，或者 W-2 员工，但通常这些是在较小的地方，你知道，工会可能只有三四个人。所以它真的行不通。而且提供者也不是真正支付你薪水的人，因为还有其他人支付他们，即保险公司。
you know, if you are a solo practitioner struggling to pay rent in a sub-lease office, seeing clients between crying in your car and eating lunch at your desk and, you know, rocking back and forth, biting a washcloth and your tub crying, you know, the law views you as the CEO of a micro corporation. And so you're classified as a 1099 independent contractor, you know, or a W-2 employee, but usually those are at smaller places, you know, where the union might be three or four people. So it doesn't really work. And then also the provider isn't the one really paying you because somebody else is paying them, the insurance company.
所以，你知道，如果你说，嘿，支付给我们比保险公司支付给你的更多的钱，五人公司的老板先生，否则我们就离开，那么企业就会倒闭，因为他们根本无法支付给你比他们得到的更多的钱。这说不通。所以如果星巴克的两名员工谈论他们的工资并同意要求加薪，那是集体谈判，因为他们都为星巴克工作。《国家劳资关系法》保护他们。但如果两名私人执业治疗师谈论他们的报销费率，然后他们同意要求蓝十字加薪，
So, you know, if you said, hey, pay us more than the insurance company pays you, Mr. owner at a five-person company or will leave, then the then. business would fail because they're just not going to be able to pay you more money than they get paid. It doesn't make sense. So if two workers at a Starbucks talk about their wages and they agree to ask for a raise, that's collective bargaining because they both work for Starbucks. The National Labor Relations Act protects them. But if two private practice therapists talk about their reimbursement rates and then they agree to ask Blue Cross for a raise
然后也许我打电话给州里的 50 个朋友，让他们打电话给他们的 50 个朋友，那是价格操纵。那是违法的。我不能那样做。如果我上一个 subreddit 说，嘿，我认为我们都应该坚持住并离开工会，你离开蓝十字网络，直到他们让我们得到这个报酬或类似的东西，这再次，
and then maybe I call 50 of my friends in the state and ask them to call 50 of their friends, that's price fixing. That's illegal. I can't do that. If I get on a subreddit and I say, hey, I think that we should all hold tight and leave the Union, you leave the Blue Cross Network until they make us get paid this or something, which again,
是一个例子，我不是在倡导那样做。我不是说我想要蓝十字汇款增加。我只是说那将是，我制造了多少噪音可能会也可能不会让某人关注我，但一旦我开始这样做，它就是违法的。所以这听起来很荒谬，但联邦贸易委员会（FTC）对此非常认真。在很多事情上这并不荒谬。这些法律应该存在。
an example, I'm not advocating for that. I'm not saying that I want Blue Cross three minutes to go up. I'm just saying that that would be, how much noise I made may or may not make somebody pay attention to me, but as soon as I start doing it, it's illegal. So it sounds absurd, but the FTC takes that seriously. And it's not absurd in a lot of things. Those laws should be there.
它们并不坏。我们以一种奇怪的方式将它们串联在一起，我稍后会讲到，但独立承包商组织起来要求更高的费率，当他们分享关于他们获得多少报酬的信息并协调他们的反应时，他们就在进行横向价格操纵，这是反托拉斯法中最严重的违规行为之一。所以《谢尔曼法》提供了刑事处罚、罚款、监禁，你知道，所有这些，
They're not bad. We've strung them together in a weird way that I'll get to, but independent contractors organized to demand higher rates, and when they share information about what they're being paid and coordinate their responses, they're engaging in horizontal price fixing, which is one of the most serious violations of the antitrust law. So the Sherman Act provides criminal penalties, fines imprisonment, you know, all that,
这些法律让你打破垄断，而现在它被用来阻止社会工作者要求生活成本调整，我并不是唯一受到这种打击的职业。如果你看看随着时间的推移生活成本，一切都贵得多。通货膨胀占了一部分，我们赚的钱并没有比以前多。只是普通工人，百万富翁赚得更多。但在你开始达到几十万之前，
that laws let you break up monopolies, and it now is used to prevent social workers from asking for a cost of living adjustment, which I'm not the only profession that's been hit by that. If you look at the cost of living over time, everything costs way more. Inflation takes a chunk, and we don't really make more than we used to. Just average workers, millionaires make more. But until you start getting up into the hundreds of thousands,
你知道，除非你超级富有，否则平均收入并没有真正上升。所以很长一段时间以来，医生和律师认为他们可以免受这些法律的约束。他们，你知道，争辩说他们是受过教育的专业人士，而不是普通的商人。所以他们高于肮脏的商业法律。但随后他们相信他们对病人和客户的道德义务使他们区别于管理钢铁厂和肉类加工厂的规则。所以医学是一种使命，而不是一种生意。医生被视为某种世俗的牧师，而律师被视为某种流氓代理人，在公正的文化下。
you know, average incomes are not really going up unless you're super wealthy. So for a long time, doctors and lawyers thought that they were exempt from these laws. And they, you know, argued and they were learned professions, not mere tradespeople. And so they were above the grubby laws of commerce. But then they believed that their ethical obligation, to patients and clients set them apart from the rules that governs steel mills and meatpacking plans. And so medicine was a calling, not a business. It was, doctors were seen as sort of like secular priests in a sense, and lawyers as kind of like rogue agents and under the just culture.
所以政府肯定不会监管这种神圣的医患关系，如果它就像商业交易一样，你知道，那是很久以前的事了。但在 1975 年，最高法院的案件，我想是 Goldfarb 诉……我不知道，弗吉尼亚州的某个人。他们，这个案件涉及律师，而不是医生，但其影响波及了美国每一个持牌职业。所以 Goldfarbs 正在购买一处房产。很多，顺便说一句，在法律上，
And so surely the government's not going to regulate this sacred patient doctor relationship if it was just like it was a commercial transaction, you know, that is a long time ago. But in 1975, the Supreme Court case, I think it was goldfarb versus. I don't know, someone in Virginia. They, the case took lawyers, not doctors, but its implications cascaded through every licensed profession in America. So the Goldfarbs were purchasing a home. A lot of, just as an aside legally,
很多影响医生和律师的事情也相互影响。这就像一个职业，它们是食物链顶端的职业，因为它们所做的事情。总之，弗吉尼亚州律师协会可能，你知道，对服务有这些最低费用。他们联系的每一位律师都报了完全相同的价格。所以他们起诉了，认为这种费用安排是非法的，因为显然他们在交谈。他们都说，比如我们没有人会以低于这个价格工作。所以最高法院在一致裁决中同意，法院裁定专业服务，
a lot of things that affect doctors also affect lawyers and vice versa. It's like a profession that is, they're the top of the food chain professions kind of for what they do. And so anyway, the Virginia state bar probably, you know, had these minimum fees for services. And every lawyer that they contacted quoted the exact same price. And so they sued arguing that this fee scheduling was illegal because obviously they're talking. They're all saying like none of us are going to work for less than this. And so the Supreme Court agreed in a unanimous decision, the court rules that professional services,
包括法律和医疗建议，是贸易或商业。所以它们受反托拉斯法约束。因此，被假定但从未真正确立的受过教育的专业豁免被宣布为神话。这不是真的。法院说，职业的性质本身并不意味着它不受《谢尔曼法》的约束。
including legal and medical advice or trade or commerce. and so they're subject to antitrust. So learn professional exemption, which had been assumed but never really established, was declared a myth. This is not real. The nature of an occupation standing alone, the court says, doesn't mean that it is not the Sherman Act.
所以仅仅因为你在一个办公室工作并不意味着你可以给你的朋友打电话，因为你们不是为同一家公司工作的。你们不是都为通用汽车工作。所以这项裁决旨在通过防止律师设定最低费用来降低消费者的价格。在狭义上，这是好的，但在医疗保健领域，它产生了灾难性的副作用。它使医生和治疗师联合起来抵制保险公司的定价权变得合法。
So just because you're working in a single office doesn't mean that you can call your friends because you don't work for the same company. You don't all work for the auto GM. And so this ruling was intended to lower prices for consumers by preventing lawyers from setting minimum fees. And in the narrow sense, it was good, but in health care, it had a catastrophic side effect. It may do the legal for doctors and therapists to band together to resist the pricing power of insurance companies.
所以受过教育的专业，因为，你知道，我们基本上都为保险公司工作。这非常困难，至少很多人的目标是达到不需要接受保险的地步。但开始一个有保险的执业非常困难。而且经营一个大型执业肯定非常困难，你知道，在地理上，你需要每种各样的一些原因。但我们现在只是企业，企业不允许手拉手，尽管我们从技术上讲，引用，都在工作，从同一个人那里获得保险汇款。所以有一种进步的错觉，我们有这个自由市场在提供者之间竞争，
And so the learned profession, because, you know, it's we all work for the insurance company, basically. It's very hard, at least a lot of people's goal is to get to a point where they don't have to take insurance. But it's very hard to start a practice with one. And it's definitely very hard to run a big practice, which the, you know, geographically, you need some of each for different reasons. but we're now just businesses, and businesses are not allowed to hold hands, even though we're all technically, quote, unquote, working, getting an insurance remit from the same person. So there's this illusion of progress that we have this free market to compete among providers,
但仍然有人在真正设定费率。所以支付者之间的这种权力，你知道，这是一个卖家被禁止组织，但买家被允许合并直到他们大到不能倒的市场。所以作为治疗师，你的老板本质上是一个垄断者。顺便说一句，伙计，有些州，我知道堪萨斯州就是其中之一。有些州撤销了它。但像蓝十字在大多数地方就像一家真正的私人公司。但在堪萨斯州，他们不知何故变成了非营利组织。
but there's still somebody who's really setting the rate. And so this power among payers, you know, it's this market where sellers are forbidden from organizing, but the buyers are allowed to merge until they are too big to fail. So the thing that is your boss as a therapist is essentially a monopoly. By the way, man, there's like some states, I know Kansas is one of them. Some of them reversed it. But like where Blue Cross is like an actual like private company, like, you know, in most places. But in like Kansas, they somehow became a nonprofit.
哦，让我，如果你知道那是怎么发生的，给我写封电子邮件，也许那是另一篇文章。但是的，所以他们获得了作为非营利组织的好处，但也像垄断，你知道，该州的保险。但作为这种执行机制的法律本身就是，你知道，阻止这个市场将太多财富转移到一个阶层的东西。所以因为我们在美国进行医疗保健的方式的结构，平衡消失了。所以如果治疗师不能串通或设定价格，如果你想知道治疗师是否可以成立工会，继续吧，剧透警告，他们不能。所以已经有一些，你知道，人们试图解决这个问题的方法。但美国医疗保健中有一个群体被允许在这个房间里开会。他们决定每个医生值多少钱。他们为整个
Ooh, let me, if you know how that one happened, write me an email, maybe that's another article. But yeah, so they got the benefits of being non-profit, but also like the monopoly, you know, insurance for the state. But the law itself serving as this enforcement mechanism was what, you know, kept this market from transferring too much wealth to one class. And so the balances kind of went away because of the structure of how we did health care in America. So if therapists can't collude or set prices, if you're wondering if a therapist can start a union, go ahead, spoiler alert, they can't. So there's been some, you know, kind of ways that people have tried to get a problem. around this, but there's one group in American health care that's not that is allowed to meet in this room. And they decide what every doctor is worth. And they set prices for the entire
行业设定价格。它被称为 RUC 或专业协会相对价值量表更新委员会。但他们认为第一部分是一个词。所以它是 RUC。我们在上一集关于 DSM 的节目中谈到了它。但我认为深入了解这一点很重要。因为我提到这一点导致医生给我发电子邮件，说我是阴谋论者，说因为我指出他们职业的经济引擎存在，而他们从未听说过这个东西。显然，它不太为人所知。但如果那些，你知道，我不会点名任何人，但如果那些
industry. And it's called the RUC or the special society relative value scale update committee. But they consider the first part one word. So it's the RUC. We talked about it in the last episode about the DSM. But I thought it was important to go into that to a little bit more detail. because when my mention of that resulted in doctors, sending me emails saying that I was a conspiracy theorist saying that because of the, I was pointing out the economic engine of their profession existed and they've never heard of this thing. Evidently, it's not very well known. But if the people that are, you know, I'm not going to call anybody out, but if the people
在他们行业中地位很高并且认为自己对此了解很多的人似乎不知道，比如，你知道，CPT 代码是由 AMA 拥有的。然后 AMA 转过身来游说保险公司要求你使用 CPT 代码进行计费。所以每个使用 CPT 代码的人，像我一样，每次我进行心理治疗服务时，你知道，我可能通过我的 EMR，我不是直接支付，向 AMA 支付版税。你知道，这怎么可以？你说全国每个人都必须使用这些我们碰巧获得版税的代码。然后你净赚 2 亿美元。那不是阴谋论。
that are very high up in their industry and think they know a lot about it don't seem to know that like, you know, CPT codes are patented by the AMA. And then the AMA turns around in lobbies for insurance companies to require that you bill with a CPP code. So everyone who's using a CPT code like me, every time I make a, every time I do a service of psychotherapy, you know, I get probably through my EMR, I don't pay it directly, pays a royalty to the AMA. You know, how is that okay? You're saying everyone in the whole country has to use these codes that we just happen to get a royalty on. And then you're netting $200 million. That's not a conspiracy theory.
那实际上是你的职业运作方式。如果你是 AMA 的成员，也许读读它是如何运作的。但无论如何，不是阴谋论。当我收到其中一些电子邮件时，我意识到这可能不太为人所知。因此，要理解当前的心理健康状况，你必须回到医生支付系统的基础。所以 1992 年，很多事情发生了变化。但在那之前，医疗补助（Medicaid）根据一种称为习惯性、普遍性和合理收费的系统来报销医生。所以在这个系统下，医生是根据他们的历史账单收费来支付的。
That's actually how your profession works. If you're a member of the AMA, maybe read about how it functions. But anyway, not a conspiracy theory. And it occurred to me when I got some of those emails that this may not be terribly well known. So to comprehend this current mental health situation, you've got to go back to the foundations of the physician payment system. So in 1992, a lot of things changed. But before that, Medicaid reimbursed physicians based on a system known as customary, prevailing, and reasonable charges. So under that system, physicians were paid based on their historical billing charges.
所以如果你收费 200 美元，然后生活成本上升，你把它提高到 220 美元，然后你把它提高到 250 美元，他们会查看那里的曲线并支付你，你知道，与你历史上一直收费的费率相称的费率。所以自由市场可以承受它。医疗补助会尝试满足它。他们不会满足得那么高，但他们会考虑到它并争取它。所以它奖励了那些最积极提高费用的人，因为如果你想开始你的执业，你不想收费 200 美元。你想收费 500 美元，因为你想
So if you've charged $200 and then cost of living goes up, you raise it to $220, then you raise it to $250, they kind of look at the curve there and pay you, you know, their rate commiserate with what you have been charging historically. So the free market can bear it. Medicaid will try and meet it. They're not going to meet it as high, but they're going to take it into consideration and shoot for it. So it rewarded those who raise their fees the most aggressively because if you wanted to start out your practice, you didn't want to charge $200. You wanted to charge $500 because you wanted
让它看起来像你的费率。所以这为相同的服务造成了这种巨大的地理差异。而那些做坏事的人，我们不应该奖励的人，却得到了奖励。所以他们决定改变它。所以 90 年代的成本正在螺旋式上升。国会通过了《综合预算调节法》。这说我们必须过渡到基于提供者所需资源的费用表。这诞生了这种相对的，或基于资源的相对价值量表。所以，这就是 RUC 设定的。所以该系统的知识架构是由哈佛大学的这个团队开发的。
that to look like what your rate was. So this created this wide geographic disparity for identical services. And the people who were kind of doing the bad thing that we shouldn't reward were getting rewarded. And so they decided to change it. So this cost are spiraling in the 90s. And Congress passed the Omnibus Budget Reconciliation Act. And that said that we had to transition to a fee schedule based on resources required to a provider. And that birthed this relative, or resource-based relative value scale. And so the, which is what the RUC sets. So the intellectual architecture for the system was developed by this team of
经济学家。哈佛团队决定存在这种医疗价值的统一理论。所以他们试图量化，再次，你知道，我在心理治疗中经常抱怨的事情。在这个背景下我没有问题，但我认为我们需要知道质量与数量的局限性，特别是在研究中。无论如何，他们想量化所有涉及的，引用，工作，涉及多少工作单位在不同的医疗行为中，然后将它们与认知强度进行比较，你需要多长时间才能变得足够聪明来做这件事。他们还想看看它涉及多少昂贵的设备。多少
economists at Harvard University. And the Harvard team decided that there was this unified theory of medical value. So they're attempting to quantify, again, you know, the thing that I complain about a lot in psychotherapy. I don't have a problem with it in this context, but I think we need to know the limits of quality versus quantity, especially in research. Anyway, they wanted to quantify all the work, quote unquote, involved, how many units of work involved in a disseparate medical acts, and then compare them to cognitive intensity, how long do it take you to get smart enough to do it. And they also wanted to look at how much expensive equipment does it involve. How much
培训，多少时间，多少昂贵的教育，多少昂贵的设备。这就是为什么，比如，每次发明某种新的、巨大的东西时，比如 UAB 买了一个，我知道这不是它实际的样子，但比如一个质子加速器来治愈癌症，然后他们以为他们会得到这些保险协议，然后他们最终没有得到他们想要的钱，所以他们在说之后就关闭了整个事情，但这就是为什么他们追逐这么多高科技的东西，特别是在手术和干预驱动的医学以及美国的医院周围，这就是全部，我们会得到一个小数字告诉你，你知道，你买了这台大机器，我们
training, how much time, how much expensive education, how much expensive equipment. It's one of the reasons why, like, every time there's like some new, huge thing invented, like UAB bought like a, I know this isn't what it actually was, but like a proton accelerated or cure cancer, and then they thought they were going to get these insurance agreements, and then they ended up not getting the money they wanted, so they just closed the whole thing down after saying, but it's why they chase so much like high-tech stuff, especially around like surgery and intervention-driven medicine and hospitals in America, that's all, we'll get a little number telling you, you know, you bought this big machine and we're
要为你报销。所以哈佛的研究是革命性的。顺便说一句，这就是为什么美国医疗保健中有这么多你在欧洲医疗保健中找不到的测试。我们做了很多证据表明我们并不真正需要的非常昂贵的测试。我们算是一种测试文化。当欧洲出现问题时，他们倾向于观察，然后如果有一种非常明显的、可预防的事情，他们倾向于观察。就像在美国，我们只是测试一切，因为它超级昂贵，你可以为此从保险中骗取很多钱。所以，你知道，承诺水平
going to reimburse you for it. So the Harvard study is revolutionary. Also, by the way, that's why there is so much testing in American health care that you don't find in European health care. We do a whole lot of really expensive tests that the evidence says we don't really need. And we're kind of a testing culture. They tend to look when there's a problem in Europe, and then they tend to look if there's a very obvious kind of preventable thing. Like in America, we just test for everything because it's super expensive and you can bilk insurance for it a whole lot. So, you know, promise to level
这个法案承诺公平竞争，暗示，你知道，像谈话这样的服务会比，你知道，初级心理健康和手术要便宜，手术将是最昂贵的，你知道，只是试图让它公平。所以如果原始委员会的建议被纯粹地实施，
this act promised to level the playing field suggesting that, you know, services that were like talking were going to be less expensive than, you know, primary mental health and surgery is going to be the most expensive, you know, just trying to make it fair. So if the recommendations of the original committee had been implemented purely,
全科医生和专科医生之间的收入差距就会缩小。所以你不会有试图一个月做 600 次足部手术的人，为了得到最多的钱。像很多，由于某种原因，我真的不明白。你确实注意到，比如，我工作的一部分是在我的车里有医学生，并且，比如，教他们关于心理健康，当我在 UAB 工作时，我做我的实地工作，因为我是门诊，寻找患有慢性无家可归和精神分裂症的人。
the income back gap between generalists and specialist would have narrowed. So you wouldn't have people trying to do like 600 foot surgeries, you know, a month in order to get the most money. Like a lot of, for some reason, I don't really understand it. You do notice, like, part of my job was to have medical students in my car and, like, teach them about mental health when I was doing my, like, field work when I worked at UAB because I was outpatient looking for people with chronic homelessness and schizophrenia.
所以医生通常，比如，如果他们在轮转中遇到精神科，那是精神科轮转。他们喜欢那样，然后你就能看到这些人，这些不同的学科。那些足部医生，伙计，他们很有野心。我不知道为什么会这样。但无论如何，你赚了很多。所以，你知道，那些人，有些人努力赚很多钱，并且，你知道，进入那个领域，不是说他们任何坏话。
And so the doctors generally, like, if they encounter psych at all in their rotation, it's like Psyche R. They liked that, and then you get to see these people, these different disciplines. Some of those foot people, man, they're ambitious. I don't know why that is. But anyway, you make a lot. So, you know, the people who, some people strive to make a lot and, you know, go into that, not say anything bad about them.
但是，将这些价值分配给超过 7,000 个，你知道，当前程序术语代码的行政复杂性，顺便说一句，这就是 CPT 代码的含义。它压倒了医疗保健融资管理局。而在那个行政真空地带，AMA 出现了，他们就像，嘿，这真的很令人困惑。你们不是医疗人员。你们不追踪这个行业。
But the administrative complexity of assigning, you know, these values to over 7,000, you know, current procedural terminology codes. It over what, which is what CPT code stands for, by the way. it overwhelms the health care financing administration. And in that administrative vacuum comes the AMA, and they're like, hey, this is like really confusing. You aren't medical people. You don't track the industry.
你们真的不知道发生了什么。需要帮助吗，兄弟。所以像 AMA，担心联邦政府会单方面设定价格，他们提议，因为他们不想让这些价格被普遍设定。他们想能够独立谈判并说，嘿，我值多一点。而且我认为全科和家庭医学，这个系统可能会通过激励更多人这样做而不是这些净赚很多的疯狂专科来得到服务。我不是说如果你是世界上唯一知道如何用蓝色激光向后替换主动脉的人，你不应该多赚一点并为你必须投入的东西报销。
You don't really know what's up. You want some help, bro. And so like the AMA, fearing that the federal government would unilaterally just set prices, they proposed, because they didn't want those prices to be universally set. They wanted to be able to negotiate independently and say, hey, I'm worth a little bit more. And I think that general and family practice medicine, the system would probably be served by incentivizing more people to do that instead of these crazy specialties that net a whole lot. And I'm not saying that if you are the only person who knows how to replace an aorta backwards or whatever with a blue laser in the world that you shouldn't make a little bit more and be reimbursed for what you have to invest in it.
我只是觉得差距很大。当你最高和最低收入的医生之间有数百万美元时，差距很大。无论如何，政府，所以 AMA 说，让我们召集这个专家委员会来维护和更新相对价值，我们将免费为政府提供这种劳动密集型服务，因为我们很好，我们想帮忙。政府就像，谢谢，伙计，那很酷。所以 91 年，RUC 诞生了。一切在 92 年改变了。如果你像我一样老，你可以记得那件事发生。比如我确实记得不太知道像公司化这样的词，不太知道。
I just think the gap is huge. When you've got millions of dollars in between the highest and lowest earning doctor, big gap. So anyway, the government, so the AMA says, let's just convene this committee of experts to maintain and update the relative values and we'll provide this labor intensive service to the government for free, which because we're nice and we want to help. And the government's like, thanks, man, that's cool. And so 91, the RUC is born. And everything changes in 92. And if you're old like me, you can kind of remember that happening. Like I do remember not really knowing the words for like corporatization, not really know.
知道它为像数据收集这样的东西写了名字，但意识到我在成长过程中处于一个不同的世界，并询问我的父母。他们没有，他们没有看到那些东西。他们是一只，你知道，在锅里煮的青蛙。所以 RUC 声称作为这个专家小组的合法性，由 AMA 最优秀的医生组成，他们最了解他们的专科。但对其构成的结构分析揭示了一种深刻的偏见，模仿了旨在保护其利益的卡特尔的治理。信不信由你，他们不仅仅是免费为联邦政府做一件好事。所以这个委员会由 32 名成员组成，但权力主要集中在 29 个投票席位中。其他人只能说话，不能投票。
knowing that it wrote the names for like data collection, but realizing that I was like in a different world as I was growing up and kind of asking my parents. And they didn't, they weren't seeing those things. They were a frog, you know, boiling in a pot. So the RUC claims legitimacy as this expert panel who, of the AMA's finest doctors who know the most about their specialty. But a structural analysis of its composition reveals that there's a profound bias. that mimics the governance of a cartel designed to protect their interests. They're not just doing a nice thing for the federal government for free, believe it or not. So this committee consists of 32 members, but power is concentrated mainly among 29 voting seats. The other ones can just talk, not vote.
然后其中 21 个由主要的国家医学专科协会任命。所以分配与提供给医疗补助受益人的服务量不成比例。你不是在观察市场然后任命这个。你是在观察专科，这在更广泛的国家医学中可能并不那么重要，因为它可能不是很常见。可能，你知道，在某些极端情况下，可能不到 100 人做某种手术，几乎在世界上，特别是如果它是新的或以某种方式超级复杂。
And then of those 21 are appointed by major national medical specialty societies. And so the distribution is not proportional with the volume of services provided to Medicaid beneficiaries. you're not looking at the market and then appointing this. You're looking at the specialty, which may not be that important in broader national medicine because it may not be very common. There may be, you know, in some extreme cases, there may be like less than 100 people that do a certain procedure almost in the world, especially if it's new or super complicated in a certain way.
专科会比那更广泛。但他们有大量的代表权，仅仅是因为他们所做的事情，而不是因为国家真正需要什么。所以执行大约 45% 到 50% 医疗补助工作的初级保健医生，他们拥有大约 4 到 5 个席位。这给了他们 17% 的投票权，17，如果我不清楚的话，17，不是 70。而程序和外科专科，包括外科、放射科、麻醉科，他们拥有 15 到 18 个席位，给了他们大约 60% 的投票权，尽管他们只执行了 35% 到 40% 的医疗保险工作。所以美国精神病学协会拥有一个席位，一个席位。而这个唯一的代表必须与专科的绝对多数谈判，神经科学、心脏、你叫什么？
Specialties are going to be broader than that. But they have a whole lot of representation just because of what they do, not because of really what the need of the country is. So primary care physicians who perform roughly 45 to 50% of Medicaid work, they hold approximately 4 to 5 seats. And that gives them 17% of the vote, 17, if I wasn't clear, 17, not 70. And procedural and surgical specialies, including surgery, radiology, anesthesiology, they hold 15 to 18 seats, giving them roughly 60% of the vote, despite performing only 35 to 40% of the Medicare work. And so the American Psychiatric Association holds a single seat and one seat. And this lone representative must negotiate with a super majority of specialists, neuroscience, cardio, what do you call?
我不知道它是什么，你知道，基本上是心脏外科医生。我知道它是心血管，无论什么，我忘记了那个专科的名字，但它不仅仅是心脏。放射科、眼科，所有这些。而那些医生有更多共同点，因为他们是正在做的专家。比如精神科医生可能与全科医生有最多的共同点，因为他们正在交谈、评估、获取信息并进行猜测，而这些其他人就像让机器人的手臂去缝合心脏或膝盖的主动脉或无论什么。而且它非常技术性。而我们在那篇 DSM 文章中谈到的那整件事
I don't know what it is, you know, basically heart surgeons. I know that it's cardiovascular, whatever, I forget the name of that specialty, but it's more than just the heart. Radiology, ophthalmology, all that. And those doctors have a lot more in common because they're experts that are doing. like the psychiatrists probably have the most in common with like general practice doctors because they're talking and assessing and getting information and making guesses, whereas these other guys are like getting a robot's arm to like suture in a order of a heart or a knee or whatever. And it's very technical. And that whole thing that we talked about in that DSM article
关于所有医生如何认为精神病学是假的或不真实的或不那么困难，那仍然是一回事。比如作为一个四年里每隔一天就有医生在车里的人。你知道，很多人仍然有点像，嘿，你知道，很多人认为精神病学在我的领域不是真的。或者他们认为它不如，但出于一个原因，让我试着让它听起来不错。
about how all the doctors kind of think that psychiatry is fake or not real or not as hard, that's still a thing. Like as someone who had doctors in their car, you know, every other day for four years. You know, a lot of people still are kind of like, hey, you know, like a lot of people don't think psychiatry is real in my field. Or they think it's less than, but for a reason that let me try and make it sound nice.
我不会列出原因清单。有时它就像，你知道，它只是你做的那个。它就像，你只是非常关心。它就像，嗯，那是一件好事。你为什么把它说成坏事？你知道，你有点知道他们在想什么。无论如何，不管怎样。所以医疗保险医生费用表是零和游戏。
I won't go through the list of reasons. Sometimes it's like, you know, it's just the one that you do. It's like, you just care a lot. It's like, well, that's a nice thing. Why are you saying it like a bad thing? You know, like, you kind of know what they're thinking. Anyway, whatever. So the Medicare physician fee schedules is zero-sum game.
所以它有点像这种卡特尔动态，由预算中立的法定要求强制执行。所以如果给定年份预测的总相对价值单位超过了预算，你知道，按比例，那么它就会减少。他们说，哦，如果我们都认为我们应该赚这么多钱，但锅里只有这么多钱，那么每个人都只会遭受 60% 的打击。所以如果每个人都认为一个人说我应该赚，你知道，1,000 美元，另一个人说，15，你得到 1,000 美元的 60% 用于你的服务，我得到 15,000 美元的 60% 用于我的。所以即使是那种按比例的减少也让它有点不公平。所以任何增加心理治疗价值的提议，这将需要增加，你知道，那个总相对价值支出，实际上要求房间里的每个其他外科医生
So it's kind of this cartel dynamic that is enforced by this statutory requirement of budget neutrality. So if the total relative value units projected for a given year exceed the budget, you know, at scale, then it's just reduced. And they say, oh, if we all think that we should make this much money, but there's only this much money in the pot, then everybody's just going to take a 60% hit. So if everybody thinks that one person says I should make, you know, $1,000 and another person says, 15, you get 60% of 1,000 for your service and I get 60% of 15,000 for mine. So even like the kind of scaled reduction makes a little bit unfair. And so the any proposal to increase the value of psychotherapy, which would need to increase, you know, that that total relative value spend effectively asks every other surgeon in the room to
接受减薪，因为他们都在相互竞争，而精神病学是最小的投票。记住一个精神病学代表代表一切，一个医生代表心理健康。其他职业根本不与心理健康发生冲突，而且它们是非常不同的技术性事情。所以鉴于通过建议需要三分之二的多数票，那么那个程序块拥有否决权，我们经历了那些减少。精神病学在 RUC 中不会通过那个。所以卡特尔的一个标志，你知道，如果你想要它，因为卡特尔在美国是非法的，
take a pay cut because they're all competing with each other and psychiatry is the tiniest vote. Remember one psychiatry rep out of everything, one doctor representing mental health. The other professions don't bump up against mental health at all, and they're pretty different technical things. So given that a two-thirds majority is required to pass a recommendation, then that procedural block holds veto power, and we went through those disreductions. Psychiatry is not going to get past that in the ruck. So a hallmark of a cartel, you know, if you want it because cartels are illegal in America,
是信息的限制。你说，嘿，我打电话给我的朋友，我说我们不会以低于这个价格为全国工作？那仍然可能被视为违反《谢尔曼法》，但它不会符合卡特尔的定义，因为我告诉你，我正在这样做。所以近二十年来，RUC 在近乎完全的保密中运作。所以虽然近年来，你知道，工会必须非常公开。投票必须公开。你在高速公路上看到标志。
is a restriction of information. Did you say, hey, I called on my friends and I said we're not working for less than this to the whole country? That still probably would be considered a violation of the Sherman Act, but it wouldn't meet the definition of a cartel because I'm telling you that, that I am doing that. So for nearly two decades, the RUC operated in near total secrecy. So while recent years, you know, unions have to be really public. The vote has to be public. You see signs on the highway.
比如，这不是秘密。如果他们在暗室里开会，他们就会惹上麻烦。虽然近年来看到了一些小的让步，比如关于透明度，他们就像，哦，也许我们应该发布谁投票支持什么，或者只是投票总数，或者真正的审议过程，你知道，会议记录，所说的话，根本不公开，没有任何部分。所以 RUC 会议是私人的，公众、媒体和每个非 RUC 医生，所以即使是医学博士也大多被禁止参加分配数十亿税款的审议。所以 32 个人决定方向，嗯，还有 29 个甚至可以开口的人。
Like, it's not a secret. If they meet in a dark room, they get in trouble. While recent years have seen some minor concessions, like about transparency where they're like, oh, maybe we should like publish who voted for what or just the vote totals or the real deliberation process, you know, the meeting minutes, what is said, is not public at all, no part of it. And so the RUC meetings are private and the public, the press, and every non-RUC physician, so even MDs are largely barred from attending the deliberations where billions of tax dollars are allocated. So 32 people decide the direction, well, and 29 that can even open their mouth.
这并不是什么秘密。如果他们在暗室里会面，他们就会惹上麻烦。虽然近年来出现了一些小的让步，比如关于透明度的问题，他们会说，哦，也许我们应该公布谁投了什么票，或者只公布投票总数，或者真正的审议过程，你知道，会议记录，说了什么，根本不公开，一点都不公开。因此，RUC会议是私下的，公众、媒体和每一位非RUC医生，甚至医学博士，在很大程度上都被禁止参加分配数十亿美元税款的审议。所以32个人决定了方向，嗯，只有29个人能开口说话。
I mean, not open their mouth, vote. The other ones can talk. And one of these people is a psychiatrist, and they're deciding where are the billions of dollars that the government's going to spend on health care that's like, your money anyway, by the way, is going to go that year. And it's completely not transparent. So participants include the specialty advisors who present the data, and they have to sign these non-disclosure agreements,
我的意思是，他们不开口，只投票。其他人可以发言。其中一个人是精神科医生，他们正在决定政府每年要在医疗保健上花费的数十亿美元——顺便说一句，这些钱本来就是你们的钱——该流向哪里。而且这完全不透明。所以参与者包括提供数据的专业顾问，他们必须签署这些保密协议，
and these agreements prevent them from discussing the specific trade-offs, deals, or arguments made within the chamber ever for the rest of their life, or they get sued. And then a former RUC participant, one of them described these agreements off the record as draconian and designed to insulate the committee from public accountability. So the government accountability office and the Center for American Progress have noted several times,
这些协议阻止他们终身讨论在会议室内达成的具体权衡、交易或争论，否则他们会被起诉。一位前 RUC 参与者私下将这些协议描述为严苛的，旨在使委员会免受公众监督。因此，政府问责局和美国进步中心曾多次指出，
like when you search for it, when you're researching an article like this, they notice the inherent conflict of interest there, that you're just kind of saying, yeah, you get to vote on your representatives, but it doesn't really matter who they are because the doctors are just going to decide this panel, and then they'll decide where the billions of dollars the representatives spend goes and who it goes too.
比如当你搜索它时，当你研究像这样的文章时，他们注意到了其中固有的利益冲突，即你只是在说，是的，你可以投票选出你的代表，但他们是谁并不重要，因为医生们会决定这个小组，然后他们会决定代表们花费的数十亿美元流向哪里，以及流向谁。
And so the individuals setting the prices are generally the same individual who receives the payment. And unlike a regulatory agency, which is a cartel feature, so unlike a regulatory agency where officials are salaried and divested of industry assets. Like they're not working.
因此，制定价格的人通常就是收取报酬的人。与监管机构不同——这是一种卡特尔特征——与官员领取薪水并剥离行业资产的监管机构不同。他们不是在工作。
They're not going to say, hey, I think I should make $800 an hour, and now I'm going to go make $800 an hour. You know, like the same reason why, like, Congress can't, like, invest in war and then go vote for a war. They can't trade stocks. They're not supposed to, like, that has to all be disclosed to look for insider training. These doctors can do that, not really the same as the stock market,
他们不会说，嘿，我觉得我应该每小时赚 800 美元，现在我要去赚每小时 800 美元。你知道，就像国会不能投资战争然后去投票支持战争一样。他们不能交易股票。他们不应该这样做，所有这些都必须披露以防内幕交易。这些医生可以这样做，虽然这和股票市场不太一样，
but they're voting on what they make, not what somebody else with them, not as a stakeholder, makes, what they are going to make. and they're all, you know, usually high-powered people in the prime of their career. So unlike a regulatory agency where officials are salaried and they don't have good, because that's the thing. It's like you could pay these people a salary like Congress people or the Senate to chair this thing. You could pay them a really good salary and then say you have expertise, come use it. And it would remove the, you know, kind of like ethics, not the biggest problem with the RUC, but kind of legal grade.
但他们是在为自己的收入投票，而不是为其他人——作为利益相关者——的收入投票，而是为他们自己将要赚取的收入投票。而且他们都是，你知道，通常是职业生涯黄金期的高权势人物。所以与官员领取薪水且没有这种问题的监管机构不同，因为这就是问题所在。你可以像给国会议员或参议员那样给这些人发工资来主持这件事。你可以给他们一份非常好的薪水，然后说你有专业知识，来用它吧。这会消除，你知道，某种程度上像道德问题，虽然不是 RUC 最大的问题，但属于法律层面的问题。
area of I'm voting on what I'm going to make. So the secrecy serves a functional purpose. It allows for log rolling. You know, a representative from orthopedics might support an inflated value for cardiology. And then in exchange, cardiology might support a knee replacement code. And now it's like the board of a company, you know, some people trying to get controlling interest. So you're saying who, which discipline has the most votes. So that isn't good. Again, NDAs. We don't know if that's happening. But there's this, I'll scratch your back if you scratch mine that always kicks down on psychiatry. And so the Department of Justice, why don't they break this up if it meets these definitions of a cartel? But the legal shield is that there was a Supreme Court doctrine that established that private entities are immune from antitrust liability when they are petitioning the government.
关于“我正在为我将要赚取的收入投票”的领域。所以这种保密性起到了功能性作用。它允许利益交换。你知道，骨科的代表可能会支持心脏病学虚高的价值。作为交换，心脏病学可能会支持膝关节置换术的代码。现在这就像一家公司的董事会，你知道，有些人试图获得控股权。所以你在说谁，哪个学科拥有最多的选票。所以这不好。再说一次，保密协议。我们不知道这是否正在发生。但有一种“你帮我挠挠背，我也帮你挠挠背”的文化，这总是压制精神病学。那么司法部，如果它符合这些卡特尔的定义，为什么不拆散它呢？但法律盾牌是最高法院的一项原则，该原则确立了私人实体在向政府请愿时享有反垄断豁免权。
So because the RUC technically, it only recommends the values. doesn't set them. I mean, Medicaid just accepts their recommendation more than 90% of the time, but like they're just a private thing that's working for free for the government doing all this hard work. They don't even get a salary. They just decide what they make that year, which is more than the salary is, by the way. You know, the RUC is protected by the First Amendment. They have the ability as a private entity to lobby the government for things that they want. And that legally, that's all they're doing. So this legal loophole allows the RUCs. to operate with a monopoly.
所以因为 RUC 在技术上只建议价值，而不设定它们。我的意思是，医疗补助计划在 90% 以上的情况下只是接受他们的建议，但他们只是一个为政府免费工作、做所有这些艰苦工作的私人机构。他们甚至没有工资。他们只是决定那一年他们赚多少钱，顺便说一句，这比工资多得多。你知道，RUC 受第一修正案保护。作为一个私人实体，他们有能力游说政府争取他们想要的东西。从法律上讲，他们所做的仅此而已。所以这个法律漏洞允许 RUC 以垄断方式运作。
But they don't have, even though they have the characteristics of a monopoly and a cartel, they don't have any of the legal characteristics. So no fear of prosecution. So the CMS, the Center for Medicaid Services, continues to go through this motion of reviewing their recommendations, and the CMS accepts those recommendations for the prices over 90% of the time. So because private insurance generally relies. is, you know, they base their rates on Medicare, this committee effectively sets the price of
但他们没有，尽管他们具有垄断和卡特尔的特征，但他们没有任何法律特征。所以不用担心被起诉。因此，CMS（医疗补助服务中心）继续走过场审查他们的建议，而 CMS 在 90% 以上的情况下接受了这些价格建议。所以因为私人保险通常依赖于此，你知道，他们根据医疗保险（Medicare）设定费率，这个委员会实际上设定了
health care for the entire country. So when you cheer because Medicaid gets cut, realize that your fancy Blue Cross benefits are going to get cut, too. It's just going to be five years later. Because one of the things that I've done, like one of the reasons why Taproot went in directions that other firms didn't, and then they overcorrected quicker, is that what I do is research the hell out of Medicaid and then research the hell out of what Blue Cross Federal. is doing. And then look at what Blue Cross Alabama is saying. Because Blue Cross Alabama says that they're going to do a lot of stuff that they'd like to do,
整个国家的医疗保健价格。所以当你为医疗补助被削减而欢呼时，要意识到你那昂贵的蓝十字福利也会被削减。只是会晚五年。因为我做过的一件事，比如 Taproot 走向其他公司没有走的方向，然后他们更快地纠正错误的原因之一，就是我所做的是对医疗补助进行彻底的研究，然后对蓝十字联邦正在做的事情进行彻底的研究。然后看看蓝十字阿拉巴马州在说什么。因为蓝十字阿拉巴马州说他们会做很多他们想做的事情，
but they get stopped. So if I prepare for just what Blue Cross is telling me they're going to do in two years, in my experience, about 60% of it that affects me happens because it changes before rollout. So I'm just, I've wasted all my time preparing for something that didn't happen. But what I can do is I can look at Medicaid, even as a therapist that does not take Medicaid,
但他们被阻止了。所以如果我只为蓝十字告诉我他们两年内要做的事情做准备，根据我的经验，大约 60% 影响我的事情会发生，因为在推出之前它会改变。所以我只是浪费了我所有的时间为一件没有发生的事情做准备。但我能做的是我可以研究医疗补助，即使作为一个不接受医疗补助的治疗师，
because we are a collective and a percentage of our income goes back into the collective to operate it and the cost of running it is cheaper than if we were all in private practice by ourselves. But that is technically, you know, fee splitting if we paid part of the Medicaid thing to this group. So we legally can't take Medicaid. But the reason that I study Medicaid is because I know that Blue Cross Federal, Blue Cross is going to follow Medicaid by about two years. Not exactly, but if Medicaid moves in a direction, they're going to move in that same direction by proximity, maybe not exact distance, maybe not exact location, but they're going to go in that direction. And that about two and a half years after that, all the Blue Cross plans in the country, which will still all be a little bit different, will start to move in the direction of Blue Cross federal.
因为我们是一个集体，我们收入的一部分会回流到集体中以维持其运作，而且运营成本比我们每个人单独开业要便宜。但从技术上讲，如果我们向这个团体支付部分医疗补助费用，那就是费用分成。所以我们在法律上不能接受医疗补助。但我研究医疗补助的原因是因为我知道蓝十字联邦、蓝十字会在大约两年后跟随医疗补助。不完全是，但如果医疗补助向某个方向发展，他们会因为接近性而向同一个方向发展，也许距离不完全一样，也许位置不完全一样，但他们会朝着那个方向前进。在大约两年半之后，全国所有的蓝十字计划，虽然它们仍然会有一点不同，但会开始向蓝十字联邦的方向发展。
So if you celebrate national Medicaid getting cut, just be aware that you're celebrating your own benefits going to get cut five years from the time that you're celebrating. So have fun. Enjoy the champagne. But if independent therapists did this thing where they gathered in a room and they set the rates, they would just face criminal prosecution. Because the bruck operates under the friction of advising the government, I mean, not friction, I'm sorry, fiction of advising the government. It's protected.
所以如果你庆祝国家医疗补助被削减，请注意你是在庆祝你自己的福利将在你庆祝后的五年内被削减。所以玩得开心。享受香槟吧。但如果独立治疗师聚集在一个房间里设定费率，他们只会面临刑事起诉。因为 RUC 在建议政府的摩擦下运作，我的意思是，不是摩擦，抱歉，是建议政府的虚构。它是受保护的。
The same regulatory framework that criminalizes therapist solidarity provides cover for this industry-wide price coordination by the most powerful specialties. And I'm not accusing anybody of a crime. I'm just reading the law of you. This is how it works. This is a, most of this is from a legal brief. I want to add, too,
将治疗师团结定为犯罪的同一监管框架，为最强大的专业领域在全行业范围内的价格协调提供了掩护。我并没有指控任何人犯罪。我只是在阅读法律。这就是它的运作方式。这是一个，大部分内容来自一份法律摘要。我还想补充一点，
that I'm not, I'm not criticizing Blue Cross or any insurance company here, other than the little small one I was talking about in the beginning, and I'm only criticizing them for where I perceive or from my understanding
我不是，我不是在这里批评蓝十字或任何保险公司，除了我一开始提到的那个小公司，我批评他们只是因为我察觉到或根据我的理解
that what things they're doing is, are not legal, and I'm not mentioning that my name. But I would love to keep seeing my Blue Cross patients. I'm not criticizing an insurance that I take. I'm not saying that they didn't anything wrong. Please don't take me out a network. I would love to keep seeing people. All I'm doing is just explaining how these things work. You could ask a lawyer. I have asked
他们所做的事情是不合法的，我没有提到我的名字。但我很乐意继续看我的蓝十字病人。我不是在批评我所接受的保险。我不是说他们做错了什么。请不要把我踢出网络。我很乐意继续看病人。我所做的只是解释这些事情是如何运作的。你可以问律师。我问过
lawyers and it's how I know some of this information. Like they review these things with you. This is just a legal review of how it works. So if it sounds like that's crazy, I'm not really saying it's crazy. I'm just telling you the law and you can decide what you think. Um, I, this is pretty much just directly, you know, I'm not, you know, using a lot of hyperbole other than that therapists. rock backward in the bathtub and bite on a washcloth and cry at the end of the day. That isn't true. I actually bite on a bar of soap. But this methodology violates several principles of statistical validity.
律师，这就是我知道其中一些信息的原因。比如他们和你一起审查这些事情。这只是对它如何运作的法律审查。所以如果听起来很疯狂，我并不是真的说它很疯狂。我只是在告诉你法律，你可以决定你怎么想。嗯，我，这几乎就是直接的，你知道，我没有，你知道，使用很多夸张手法，除了治疗师在浴缸里向后倒，咬着毛巾哭泣。那不是真的。我实际上咬的是一块肥皂。但这种方法违反了统计有效性的几个原则。
The surveys are voluntary and distributed by the specialty societies themselves, and the respondents are typically those most active in the society that they're in. So they're like the hobnobbers and professional or whatever. They got a lot of. So the most critical variable in the RUC equation is, time. So the work that the RVU is conceptually derived from that RVU is like the value scale that the RUC uses, sorry a lot of acronyms. You know, work equals time multiplied by intensity. Is it hard and how long does it take? That's basically the biggest variables in the
调查是自愿的，由专业协会自己分发，受访者通常是他们所在协会中最活跃的人。所以他们就像社交达人或专业人士之类的。他们有很多。所以 RUC 方程式中最关键的变量是时间。所以 RVU 的工作概念上源于 RVU，RVU 就像 RUC 使用的价值量表，抱歉，缩写太多了。你知道，工作等于时间乘以强度。它难吗？需要多长时间？这基本上是决定你一项服务赚多少钱的最大变量，
formula that decide how much you make for a service. And so therefore, inflating the time is the most direct route to inflating the prices. A lot of these things don't actually take as long in practice as they claim that they do on the, uh, in the RUC. And so independent studies by like, I ran an urban institute were two that I pulled that looked like the biggest and most comprehensive. They use, you know, objective data like operating room logs, um, to see like how long was the patient actually being operated on.
公式。因此，夸大时间是提高价格最直接的途径。其中许多事情在实践中实际上并不像他们在 RUC 上声称的那样耗时。因此，像我运行的城市研究所这样的独立研究是我提取的两个看起来最大、最全面的研究。他们使用，你知道，客观数据，比如手术室日志，来看看病人实际上被手术了多长时间。
medical records tend to not be fraudulent most of the time, and if they are not for very long. When they look at, you know, what they say it takes to do it versus how much time they do it in, like one procedure valued by Ruck that takes 60 minutes in reality just took 30 for everybody. You know, some 20, some 40, average it together 30. And this creates an arbitrage opportunity. So if a gastroenterologist can perform a 60-minute colonoscopy in 20 minutes, They can effectively perform three procedures in the time allotted for one. And they bill for three hours of work in one hour of real time.
医疗记录大多数时候往往不是欺诈性的，即使是，也不会持续太久。当他们查看，你知道，他们声称做这件事需要的时间与他们实际花费的时间相比时，比如一个被 RUC 评估为需要 60 分钟的手术，实际上每个人只用了 30 分钟。你知道，有的 20 分钟，有的 40 分钟，平均起来 30 分钟。这创造了一个套利机会。所以如果一名胃肠科医生可以在 20 分钟内完成 60 分钟的结肠镜检查，他们实际上可以在分配给一项手术的时间内完成三项手术。他们在一个小时的实际时间内为三个小时的工作开账单。
So they're able to say, hey, an hour of my time is worth $800. But then they do three one hour procedures in an hour. And now an hour of your time is worth 800 times three. So that is an efficiency gain that the free market people say is making the system be efficient by incentivizing what exactly. But anyway, psychotherapy, it can't utilize. that because the CBT code for psychotherapy is based on time. Like if you come to see me for the first time, um, it's a 907.9.1. It's an intake. And then there'll be a 90834 if you're, if I'm going to see you for, um, you know, 45 minutes. And if you want to see me for 50 minutes,
所以他们能够说，嘿，我一个小时的时间价值 800 美元。但随后他们在一个小时内完成了三项一小时的手术。现在你一个小时的时间价值 800 乘以 3。所以这是自由市场人士所说的通过激励什么来使系统变得高效的效率提升。但无论如何，心理治疗，它无法利用这一点，因为心理治疗的 CBT 代码是基于时间的。比如如果你第一次来看我，嗯，这是一个 907.9.1。这是一个摄入。然后如果你要来看我，嗯，你知道，45 分钟，就会有一个 90834。如果你想让我看 50 分钟，
it's going to be not, or 53 minutes, it's going to be 908.37. So there's no way for me to do, uh, because it's a time based procedure. I can't do 53 minutes. of therapy four times in an hour. So a psychiatrist can't perform 60 minute therapy session in 20 minutes. Doing so would be fraudulent. And like, I don't know, one of my friends, you got to make this anonymous, but like one of my friends knew a doctor who was not very nice to him. And the guy was like world famous for his specialty.
那将是，或者 53 分钟，那将是 908.37。所以我没有办法做，因为这是一个基于时间的手术。我不能在一个小时内做四次 53 分钟的治疗。所以精神科医生不能在 20 分钟内完成 60 分钟的治疗疗程。这样做将是欺诈性的。而且，我不知道，我的一个朋友，你得把这个匿名化，但我的一个朋友认识一个对他不太友好的医生。那个人在他的专业领域是世界闻名的。
And he would do, he made like an insane amount of money because he would do the procedure like more so than any other. doctor on earth. Like he had more like in, you know, procedure hours. And the reason was that he would do like six things in an hour that normally took people like an hour and a half. And so he was just like frantic all the time and like had all this energy and was like this workaholic. But it was like to cram as many people as he could see like the smallest amount of time. And he was like, we're old known because he had like the most hours doing it. So he could like lecture and he was seen as this expert. But I was just kind of like, man, if I ever need that process, that really important
他赚了惊人的钱，因为他做手术的次数比地球上任何其他医生都多。就像他有更多的，你知道，手术时间。原因是他会在一个小时内做六件通常需要人们一个半小时才能做完的事情。所以他总是很狂躁，精力充沛，是个工作狂。但这就像是为了在最短的时间内塞进尽可能多的人。他很有名，因为他做手术的时间最多。所以他可以讲课，被视为专家。但我当时只是觉得，伙计，如果我需要做那个非常重要的
procedure done, I think that I'm going to go to somebody who's going to take a full hour to do it, not be like, you know, flicking the blood off the scalpelter, run in the next room. So again, I don't know that guy. I'm not using his name, not accusing him of any wrongdoing, but that's kind of how it works. So the RUC's bias is not just structural. It's also a philosophy. The committee is dominated by surgeons and proceduralists, and they consistently value, value procedure, doing things to people, cutting, scanning, injecting, any kind of test, more so than talking to people. That's a thing that they bill for a consultation, but that's not why they make their money.
手术，我想我会去找一个愿意花整整一个小时来做的人，而不是像，你知道，把手术刀上的血甩掉，跑进下一个房间。所以再说一次，我不认识那个人。我没有使用他的名字，没有指控他有任何不当行为，但这就是它的运作方式。所以 RUC 的偏见不仅仅是结构性的。它也是一种哲学。委员会由外科医生和程序专家主导，他们始终认为程序、对人做事情、切割、扫描、注射、任何种类的测试，比与人交谈更有价值。那是他们为咨询开账单的事情，但那不是他们赚钱的原因。
So in 2013, this major revision of psychiatry codes exposes this bias and really broadly because previously psychiatrists used codes that bundled the medical evaluation with psychotherapy. So, you know, when you watch a TV show, I remember watching the TV show, evil. I know I mentioned that before, but the doctor just like stops therapy in the middle and is like, oh, wait a minute, how much lithium you're on? I'm going to adjust that right now. And it's like, oh, they don't do that anymore. And then like a case, and then she says something else. And then he's like, oh, anxiety too. I'm going to actually scratch that one. The joke is that he changes the meds three times or something. But psychopharm is now separate. So the new system
所以在 2013 年，精神科代码的这次重大修订暴露了这种偏见，而且非常广泛，因为以前精神科医生使用将医疗评估与心理治疗捆绑在一起的代码。所以，你知道，当你观看电视节目时，我记得观看电视节目《邪恶》（Evil），我知道我之前提到过，医生只是在治疗中途停下来，说，哦，等一下，你服用了多少锂？我现在要调整一下。就像，哦，他们不再那样做了。然后像一个案例，然后她说了一些别的话。然后他说，哦，还有焦虑。我实际上要划掉那个。笑话是他换了三次药之类的。但精神药理学现在是分开的。所以新系统
requires psychiatrists to bill this EM code for the medical management plus this add-on code for psychotherapy. So it's not even its own code for psychiatrists. It's just this add-on code to changing the medicine of the patient, which is the real moneymaker code that they all do. And some psychiatrists that I've talked to, actually most psychiatrists that I talk to, which I think says more about the psychiatrist that I talk to than the nature of like what most psychiatrists think because I talk to a specific type. But they don't like this. They wish that they could spend more time with patients.
要求精神科医生为医疗管理开具这个 EM 代码，加上这个心理治疗的附加代码。所以这甚至不是精神科医生自己的代码。它只是改变病人药物的附加代码，这是他们都做的真正的赚钱代码。我交谈过的一些精神科医生，实际上我交谈过的大多数精神科医生，我认为这更多地说明了我交谈过的精神科医生，而不是大多数精神科医生的想法，因为我交谈的是特定类型的人。但他们不喜欢这样。他们希望他们能花更多时间与病人在一起。
They wish that they could, but they also have to pay for med school and like all of these things. And so while it's intended to improve transparency, the change exposed that psychotherapies, therapy, it exposed it to the Rucks evaluation. And so by isolating the therapy component, the committee could subject it to rigorous cross specialty comparison. And the committee is dominated by surgeons again. And they view talking to a patient as low intensity work to operating on a patient.
他们希望他们能，但他们也必须支付医学院的费用，以及所有这些事情。因此，虽然它旨在提高透明度，但这一变化将心理治疗暴露在 RUC 的评估之下。因此，通过隔离治疗部分，委员会可以将其置于严格的跨专业比较之下。委员会再次由外科医生主导。他们认为与病人交谈是比对病人进行手术强度更低的工作。
Like, I'm fixing a heart. You're just talking about his mom. I'm better than you is generally the vibe most doctors that I've talked to kind of feel. And so this created this 15 minute med check culture. because that's a psychoform that can count as psychoform for a hospital to bill, a psychopharmacology session. But again, man, like, have you ever been to a psychiatrist and your visit was five minutes? Right?
就像，我在修复心脏。你只是在谈论他的妈妈。我比你强，这通常是大多数我交谈过的医生所感受到的氛围。所以这创造了这种 15 分钟的药物检查文化。因为那是精神药理学，可以算作医院开账单的精神药理学，精神药理学疗程。但再说一次，伙计，你有没有去看过精神科医生，你的访问只有五分钟？对吧？
Like, how many people are even getting the 15 minutes, which is not enough to implement the complexity of these diagnoses that we talked about over the last three episodes? So it's not really because psychiatrists stopped caring. It's because their profession, you know, that got being an MD, made this, structural decision that really devalued them. And because of the regulatory environment, it made relational care, just financial suicide. You couldn't do it at the same time that the cost of medicine, med school is just going through the roof and it effectively illegalized the practice of deep, slow psychiatry for anyone who wanted to take insurance. You know, I have a really great one
就像，有多少人甚至得到了 15 分钟，这不足以实施我们在过去三集中讨论的这些诊断的复杂性？所以这并不是因为精神科医生不再关心了。这是因为他们的职业，你知道，成为医学博士，做出了这个结构性的决定，真正贬低了他们。而且由于监管环境，它使关系护理变成了财务自杀。你不能在医学院成本飞涨的同时这样做，它实际上使任何想接受保险的人进行深度、缓慢的精神病学实践变得非法。你知道，我有一个非常棒的
who talks to me for an hour, but it's a CR&P. So when therapists ask about collective bargaining, lawyers will often point out the only loophole available is called the messenger model. This would be one of the ways that psychotherapy could do something. I don't think it's a great option, but it is one that people pointed out. So, you know, in that model, this third party is a messenger that acts as an intermediary between a group of providers and an insurance company. And so the messenger takes the insurance company's offer and conveys it to each therapist individually. So you could have a messenger that just talk to all the therapists in the state that signed up for this med list
人，他和我谈了一个小时，但那是 CR&P。所以当治疗师询问集体谈判时，律师通常会指出唯一可用的漏洞称为“信使模型”。这将是心理治疗可以做的事情之一。我不认为这是一个很好的选择，但它是人们指出的一个选择。所以，你知道，在这种模式下，这个第三方是一个信使，充当一组提供者和保险公司之间的中介。所以信使接受保险公司的提议，并将其分别传达给每个治疗师。所以你可以有一个信使，只与该州所有签署了这份药物清单的治疗师交谈，
that kind of lobbied on their behalf. you'd have to come up with some way to pay the guy, but each therapist must then make a unilateral independent decision to accept or reject it. They couldn't get together and say, come on guys, we've got to agree on a number. That's a cartel. They could all just say, I would work for about $150 an hour to one guy, and then that guy would get what the others say, but they couldn't all talk about it. And so the messenger is strictly forbidden from negotiating. All they can say is most therapists say that they want to be around this number. And they can't say the group rejects that.
这在某种程度上代表他们进行了游说。你必须想出某种方法来支付那个人的费用，但每个治疗师必须随后做出单方面的独立决定来接受或拒绝它。他们不能聚在一起说，来吧伙计们，我们必须就一个数字达成一致。那是卡特尔。他们都可以只说，我愿意为一个人每小时工作大约 150 美元，然后那个人会得到其他人说的，但他们不能谈论它。所以信使被严格禁止谈判。他们只能说，大多数治疗师说他们想在这个数字左右。他们不能说该团体拒绝了那个。
You have to bring it up or they're going to leave. So there's no bargaining that is possible. You're basically, you're just getting a bunch of people to hire a lobbyist that probably wouldn't do much. Therapists and social workers probably don't have as much money as these other things either. A lot of the AMA's lobbying is paid by the fact that they own CPT codes and receive royalties from that. And then there's a lot of other money in health care for different reasons,
你必须提出来，否则他们会离开。所以没有可能的谈判。你基本上只是让一群人雇佣一个可能不会做太多事情的游说者。治疗师和社会工作者可能也没有像这些其他东西那么多的钱。美国医学会（AMA）的大部分游说费用是由他们拥有 CPT 代码并从中获得版税这一事实支付的。而且医疗保健中还有很多其他原因的钱，
especially around Psychoform. but that also gets pointed out to me a lot. Like I just need to be yelling about how drug companies run the world. And I don't like drug companies being able to operate regularly deregulated. Or that isn't something that I approve of. It's just that I think a lot of those critiques are very surface level. And they assume that people get in the back room and they like rub their hands and smoke cigars and scheme. If you want to find a group doing that, that isn't really how cycle like cycle far.
特别是在精神药理学方面。但这也被很多人指出来。就像我只需要大喊大叫关于制药公司如何统治世界。我不喜欢制药公司能够被监管，或者说被去监管。或者那不是我赞同的事情。只是我认为很多这些批评非常表面化。他们假设人们进入密室，然后他们搓着手抽雪茄并策划。如果你想找到一个这样做的小组，那并不是心理治疗，像精神药理学。
that isn't how like farmological companies like actually lobby like what they do is is probably worse than that but if you want to find like one group that's a small group that has a lot of power that meets regularly it looks like this entity that nobody talks about the ruck so if it follows the messenger model if we you know therapists did that it would just kind of be you'd be telling people that you kind of wanted to make more and they probably wouldn't care um so the other option that some people have talked about is that you could like murder all the therapists in the state into one business somehow, but I don't really see a viable path to doing that. I don't see a solution other than, you know, kind of a structural change here.
那不是像制药公司实际上游说的方式，他们所做的可能比那更糟，但如果你想找到一个拥有大量权力、定期开会的小团体，它看起来就像这个没人谈论的实体——RUC。所以如果它遵循信使模型，如果我们，你知道，治疗师那样做了，那只会是你告诉人们你想要赚更多钱，而他们可能根本不在乎。嗯，所以有些人谈论的另一个选择是，你可以以某种方式将该州所有的治疗师合并成一家企业，但我真的没有看到实现这一点的可行途径。除了，你知道，这里的一种结构性改变，我没有看到其他解决方案。
I don't think there's a whole lot like the individual could do. But so like if a cartel sets a price that's below market equilibrium, suppliers just exit the market. So this is precisely what happened in psychotherapy. Mental health providers generally have lowered, they have lower overhead than surgeons. They don't need MRI machines or sterile utensil, you know, sterolizing pans for surgical stuff or diamond-tipped knives. And they face these high consumer demands. The national mental health crisis ensured the steady stream of people seeking the service. And so this gives them an exit option that the proceduralists don't have. So they can refuse to accept insurance and just be a cash-only business, which one of the reasons that I wanted to start taproot was because
我不认为个人能做很多事情。所以，如果一个卡特尔设定的价格低于市场均衡价格，供应商就会退出市场。这正是心理治疗中发生的事情。心理健康提供者的管理费用通常比外科医生低。他们不需要核磁共振机器或无菌器皿，你知道，用于手术的消毒盘或金刚石刀。而且他们面临着高消费者需求。全国性的心理健康危机确保了寻求服务的人源源不断。所以这给了他们一个程序专家没有的退出选择。所以他们可以拒绝接受保险，只做现金业务，这也是我想创办 Taproot 的原因之一，因为
what I noticed was that there were these places that were full of people and they were revolving door. Therapist came out and then they left. They didn't last long. So you got a lot of kind of lower quality people who weren't going to be great. And then you got people who were just okay with somebody taking 60, 70 percent of their paycheck forever who, you know, generally there's a reason for that. They couldn't do something on their own.
我注意到的是，有些地方挤满了人，而且是旋转门。治疗师来了，然后他们离开了。他们没持续多久。所以你得到了很多质量较低的人，他们不会很棒。然后你得到了那些只是满足于有人永远拿走他们 70% 薪水的人，你知道，通常是有原因的。他们自己做不到什么。
Some of them were fine. And then you had great therapists who all left, you know, as soon as their contract was up, they either bought out of it or they worked it off and then they left and then they went to private practice and they didn't. take insurance and they had this money. And, you know, I could have had a cool office and then you'd be alone and you'd be the king of your little room or whatever. And that's fine. But I really liked collaboration and an institute model. And you don't see things like at the colleges anymore. You know, like Berkeley of the 1970s or Eastland, you know, like these places where so much of the
他们中的一些人很好。然后你有很棒的治疗师，他们都离开了，你知道，一旦他们的合同到期，他们要么买断它，要么做完它，然后他们离开了，然后他们去私人开业，他们不接受保险，他们有这笔钱。而且，你知道，我可以有一个很酷的办公室，然后你会孤身一人，你会成为你小房间的国王之类的。那很好。但我真的很喜欢合作和研究所模式。你再也看不到像大学里那样的东西了。你知道，像 1970 年代的伯克利或伊斯特兰，你知道，这些地方，我们仍然使用的很多东西都是在那里发明并出来的。就像我没看到那些东西存在。我真的很想把最聪明的人聚集在一个地方。你这样做的方法是说，我会确保你在这里赚的钱比你自己赚的多。这是一个非常艰难的项目，做一些在纸面上是 99 合同的事情，但他们都有发言权，它的运作更像一个社会主义集体，因为，你知道，从技术上讲我可以做任何我想做的事，但我没有。他们信任我。到目前为止，这就是我所做的。
stuff that we still use was invented and came out of them. Like I didn't see those things existing. And I really wanted to get the smartest people in one place. And the way you do that is you say, I'm going to make sure that you make more money here than you would make by yourself. And that has been this really hard project of doing something that is on paper at a 99 contract, but they all have a say and it operates a little bit more like a socialist collective because, you know, I technically could do whatever I wanted, but I don't. And they trust me. And so far, this is what I've done.
所以确实存在这种大规模外流。所以部分原因是为什么会出现合格精神科医生的危机，他们实际上，实际上，实际上不仅仅是为你诊断开出他们最喜欢的鸡尾酒，而是真正倾听你的心声，是因为没有多少人最终从事精神病学，因为它不是收入最高的。医院想要接生婴儿和治疗但不治愈癌症。这就是他们的广告和广告牌上的内容，因为那是他们赚钱的地方。他们不想要精神科，你知道，他们有点不得不拥有它们。
So there is this mass exodus. So part of this is why there's this crisis of qualified psychiatrists who actually actually actually don't just put you on their favorite cocktail for your diagnosis, but like really listen to you is that not a lot of people end up in psychiatry because it's not the top earner. Hospitals want to deliver babies and treat but not cure cancer. That's what's in their advertisements and billboards because that's where they make money. They don't want psychords, you know, they kind of have to have them.
然后精神病学的自由很难。所以，你知道，我找到的最后的东西或调查是 2023 年的。64% 的私人执业治疗师计划提高他们的现金支付率，就像他们要提高成本一样。但是，通常你会看到这一点。现金支付率上升。保险费率保持不变。
And then free on the psychiatry is hard. So, you know, the last stuff. that I found or survey was like 2023. And 64% of private practice therapists plan to increase their cash pay rates, like they were going to raise the cost. But, and usually you'll see that. The cash pay rate goes up. The insurance rate stays the same.
所以更多的人离开了网络。这也造成了精神科医生的外流，60% 的精神科医生不接受保险。而且它非常昂贵。然后即使你得到了保险，就像我们有一年有一个计划。我家里有很多人需要去。他们说，好吧，在你做了这个之后我们会付钱。我们，就像，把它加起来。
So more people leave the network. And then it also created this exit of psychiatrists where 60% of psychiatrists don't take insurance. And it's incredibly expensive. And then even if you get it in insurance, like we had a plan one year. and so many of my family needed to go. And they were like, well, we'll pay money after you've done this. And we, like, added it up.
就像，我们必须一年去 19 次精神科医生那里，保险才会支付任何费用。就像，对于正常的，我是一个嫁给老师的社会工作者，那是一个相对好的，你知道，医疗保健计划。我的意思是，我们并没有富得流油，但保险相当不错。而且，如果我一周去两次精神科医生那里，我不知道，那么我想最终我可以让保险支付它，但通常没人需要那么频繁地换药。所以那种大规模外流是，你知道，RUC 压制精神病学费率的经济压力。
And it was like, I would we have to be going to the psychiatrist like 19 times a year before insurance would cover anything. Like, and that was a relatively good, you know, healthcare plan for, you know, normal, I'm a social worker married to a teacher. I mean, we're not rolling in it, but the insurance was pretty good. And like, if I went to the psychiatrist like two times a week, I don't know, then I guess eventually I could make insurance pay for it, but like nobody needs to change meds that much usually. So that mass exodus is this, you know, economic pressure to the RUC's suppressed rates for psych.
所以如果 RUC 说通过 RVU 一小时的治疗价值 100 美元，那么市场需求是 250 美元。提供者将离开 RUC 控制的空间。他们根本不会处理保险，因为他们可以在这里赚到这笔钱。而且会有很多有心理健康问题的富人去看精神科医生。通常，那些人已经满了。
So if the RUC says an hour of therapy is worth $100 via the RVU, then the market demand is 250. the provider is going to leave the RUC controlled space. They're not going to deal with insurance at all because they can make this money over here. And there are going to be a lot of rich people that have mental health problems and see the psychiatrist. Generally, those people are full.
所以他们并没有放弃他们的职业。他们正在放弃这种他们不喜欢、我也不喜欢的定价制度，通常是关于精神病学拥有多少权力。所以这真的不是你精神科医生的错，就像这不是你治疗师的错。所以那个 RCEU，定价失败创造了这些幽灵网络。所以很多这些中层保险计划，
And so they're not abandoning their profession. They're abandoning this pricing regime that they don't like and I don't like, generally, where how much power psychiatry has. So it's not really your psychiatrist's fault any more than it's your therapist's fault. And so that RCEU, pricing failure creates these ghost networks. So a lot of these like mid-tier insurance plans,
他们在网络内有 2,000 人，你给他们所有人打电话，他们要么死了，要么在外州，或者像，哦，我不再看那个保险了。他们只是把我留在他们的名单上，因为他们从法律上讲永远不需要把任何人从名单上拿下来。他们可以列出任何曾经在网络里的人，而我不想再在那个网络里了。你知道，这不是绝对意义上的提供者短缺。这是治疗师的短缺。私人执业的治疗师并不短缺。历史上比以往任何时候都多。这是愿意在 RCU 确定的价格点工作的治疗师的短缺。而保险目录就像这些墓地。就像当你浏览时，如果你给所有那些人打电话，你可能会在
they have 2,000 people in network and you call all of them and they're like dead or out of state or like, oh, I don't really see that insurance anymore. They just leave me on their list because they don't ever have to take anyone off legally. They can just list anybody who used to be in the network and I don't want to be in that network anymore. You know, this is not a shortage of providers in the absolute. It's a shortage of therapists. There's not a shortage of therapists in private practice. Like there's historically more than ever. It's a shortage of therapists that are willing to work at an RCU determined price point. And the insurance directories are just these graveyards. Like when you go through, if you call all of those people, you maybe get a call back in
一些研究中得到大约 30% 的人回电，保险公司声称他们正在接受新病人。所以 RUC 捍卫者的核心论点是他们控制成本，但严格管理，你知道，他们应该节省纳税人的钱。就像，那是他们组织的目的。我看着这些信息的问题是，这真的在发生吗？这就是他们证明自己的方式，他们真的在做他们所说的事情吗？所以在心理治疗中，这种逻辑有点适得其反，因为通过将报销率压低到驱使提供者离开网络的水平，RUC 迫使病人进入现金市场。所以理论上的网络内成本可能是 20 美元的共付额，而保险公司实际上支付，
some studies from like 30% of the people that the insurance company claims are taking new patients. And so the central thesis of the RUC's defenders is that they control costs, but strictly managing, you know, the value they're supposed to be saving the taxpayer money. Like, that's the point of their organization. You know, my question looking at this information is, is that really happening? That's how they justify themselves as are they really doing what they say they are. So in psychotherapy, this logic kind of backfires because by suppressing reimbursement rates to a level that drives providers out of the network, then the RUC forces, patients into the cash market. And so the theoretical in-network costs might be a $20 copay and the insurer is actually paying,
你知道，100 美元中的 80 美元。但实际的网络外成本是 250 美元，由病人全额支付现金。因此，消费者的治疗成本正在上升，即使看起来，好吧，为什么人们不去接受治疗，因为保险公司支付的费用比以前多了？所以治疗变成了这种奢侈品，这种只有那些有可支配收入的人才能获得的商品，这，就像我们在上一集中讨论的那样，很多这些变量是系统性的，它们对不富裕的人影响更大，
you know, $80 of the $100. But the actual out-of-network cost is $250, cash out-of-pocket paid in full by the patient. And so thus the cost of therapy for the consumer is going up, even though it looks like, well, why aren't people going to therapy because insurance companies are paying for it more than they used to? And so therapy becomes this luxury good, this accessible only, to those people with disposable income, which, like we talked about in the last one, a lot of these variables are systemic and they affect people who are not rich more,
我认为他们应该获得治疗。所以对于穷人和中产阶级来说，成本实际上是无限的，因为服务变得无法获得。所以 RUC 对系统的成本控制措施变成了病人的成本乘数。然后它将财务负担从它所属的风险池转移到个人身上，在那里它造成了最大的伤害。保险的目的是你汇集风险，这样当你有什么东西时，你有一个风险概率，当那个风险发生时，你得到了覆盖。但当你面临心理健康风险时，很多时候你找不到一个真正治疗你所患疾病的人，而那个人在你的保险网络内。
and they should have access to treatment, I think. And so for the poor in the middle class, the cost is effectively infinite because the service becomes inaccessible. And so the RUC's cost control measure for the system becomes a cost multiplier for the patient. And then it shifts the financial burden from the risk pool where it belongs to the individual, where it causes the maximum harm. The point of insurance is that you're pooling risk so that when you have something, you have a probability of risk, and when that risk happens, you're covered. But when you have the risk of a mental health thing, a lot of times you can't find somebody who actually treats what you got who's in your insurance network.
所以 RUC 向做出职业决定的医学生发送了这些强大的经济信号。当学生观察到皮肤科医生或放射科医生可以在正常工作时间或更短时间内赚取 500,000 美元，而精神科医生赚取 240,000 美元，处理情感创伤和随叫随到的紧急情况时。而且如果他们做的事情不是很有趣，那就是每 15 分钟，他们就在为另一种药物开处方，而且他们完全满了，他们整天都这样做。我的意思是，这不是我想做的事情。
And so the RUC sends these powerful economic signals to medical students making their career decision. When a student observes that a dermatologist or a radiologist can earn $500,000 working regular hours or less, then a psychiatrist is earning $240,000, handling emotional trauma and on-call emergencies. And that's if they're doing something that's not really fun, which is just every 15 minutes, they're prescribing another med and they're totally full, and they just do that all day. I mean, it's not what I want to do.
那听起来并不特别令人满足。我还在那里工作时，医院的社会工作者总是抱怨，他们说，你不希望你只是成为一名护士吗？你会有硕士学位。我们有硕士学位，我们一年赚 30,000 美元。而他们只是有副学士学位，他们赚 70,000 美元。就像，是的，但那样你就必须做护理工作。如果我想做护理工作，我会成为一名护士。
That doesn't sound particularly fulfilling. The social workers of the hospital used to always complain when I worked there, and they were like, don't you wish you'd just become a nurse? You'd have a master's degree. We have master's degrees, and we make $30,000 a year. And like, they just have an associate's degree and they make $70,000. It's like, yeah, but then you have to do nursing stuff. If I wanted to do nursing stuff, I would become a nurse.
我不想。卡特尔的定价结构，抱歉，卡特尔式的定价结构在公共卫生最需要的领域造成了永久性的劳动力短缺，这些领域是，你知道，被贬值的全科医学，和被贬值的精神病学。这两件事可能会影响最多的人。就像大多数人一生中不会有什么专业，你知道，膝盖盘，重新调整手术。有些人可能会，他们应该获得它。但那不是大多数美国人遇到医疗保健的情况。你知道，心脏病学相对普遍，但不如心理健康普遍，也不如全科医学普遍。然而他们在 RUC 上拥有所有的权力。
I don't. The cartels pricing structure, I'm sorry, the cartel-like pricing structure creates a perpetual labor shortage in the fields with the most needed for public health, which are, you know, general practice medicine, which is devalued, and psychiatry, which is devalued. The two things that will probably affect the most people. Like most people are not going to have some specialty, you know, knee disc, readjustment surgery in their lifetime. Some might, and they should have access to it. But that is not the majority of Americans encountering health care. You know, cardiology is like relatively common, but not as common as mental health and not as common as general practice medicine. Yet they kind of have all of the power on the RUC.
我不这么认为。这种卡特尔式的定价结构，抱歉，这种类似卡特尔的定价结构，导致公共卫生最需要的领域长期劳动力短缺，也就是全科医学，它被贬值了，还有精神病学，它也被贬值了。这两件事可能会影响最多的人。大多数人一生中可能不会去做什么特殊的膝盖椎间盘调整手术。有些人可能会，他们也应该有权获得这种服务。但这并不是大多数美国人接触医疗保健的情况。你知道，心脏病学相对普遍，但不如心理健康普遍，也不如全科医学普遍。然而，他们在RUC上几乎拥有所有的权力。
So the question is why can't therapists start a union that I opened with? Well, it's not just a labor question. It's a window into this kind of broken American health care system because we've built this system where a secret committee of proceduralists who most of us will never need or encounter can legally fix. the price to favor surgery over therapy, usually incredibly highly specific surgery that most people won't need, but a group of social workers can't band together and ask for a living wage. You know, we've utilized laws that are meant to break up standard oil and to break up the solidarity of the people that are trying to keep our kids healthy. And the same regulatory framework that criminalizes a therapist coordinating, you know, legal cover, the same framework that stops
所以问题是，为什么治疗师不能像我开头说的那样成立工会？嗯，这不仅仅是一个劳工问题。它是美国医疗体系破碎的一个缩影，因为我们建立了一个系统，在这个系统中，一个大多数人永远不会遇到或需要的程序专家秘密委员会，可以合法地将价格定得偏向手术而非治疗，通常是大多数人根本不需要的、极其具体的手术，但一群社会工作者却不能联合起来要求获得生活工资。你知道，我们利用了那些旨在拆分标准石油公司、旨在瓦解那些试图保护我们孩子健康的人们团结的法律。而同样的监管框架，将治疗师协调法律保障的行为定为犯罪，同样的框架也阻止了
me from coordinating with somebody else, which I'm not saying I want to do, just as a hypothetical, also lets the cost of health care creep up every single year for every person. And the result is this regulatory environment that drives doctors crazy, but it burns out therapists. And it leaves patients navigating this fragment assembly line system that was never designed to heal them. You know, like half the time I need to do a consult with a psychiatrist. I don't hear back from them for three months. And I'm not blaming them. They're busy. they've added so much paperwork to the system that becomes like a huge amount of what they have to do
我与其他人进行协调——我并不是说我想这样做，只是假设一下——同时也让医疗成本每年都在为每个人上涨。结果就是这种监管环境让医生发疯，却让治疗师精疲力竭。它让患者在这一支离破碎的流水线系统中挣扎，而这个系统根本不是为了治愈他们而设计的。你知道，就像我有一半时间需要咨询精神科医生，三个月都收不到回复。我并不是在责怪他们，他们很忙。他们给系统增加了太多的文书工作，以至于这成了他们必须做的大部分工作，
and they don't have time to even talk to the therapist you probably knows the patient better and it's not because they don't want to a lot of the time sometimes they don't want to talk to me but until we confront the legal architecture of that system the RUC that Sherman Act is just this trap that says hey you all get paid by one guy but you don't work for him so you have zero power
他们甚至没有时间去和可能更了解病人的治疗师交谈，这并不是因为他们不想，很多时候他们是不想和我谈，但在我们面对该系统的法律架构之前，RUC（相对价值更新委员会）和谢尔曼反托拉斯法就像一个陷阱，它告诉你：嘿，你们所有人都是由同一个人发工资，但你们并不为他工作，所以你们毫无权力。
and the reality of therapy is that quick fixes which insurance generally prefers you know, are the ones that end up costing more in the end. You know, the biggest reason that people go to the ER in this country or for chronically is like for conditions that could have been prevented, you know, and the people that are just like, well, no one's going to stop you from going to the ER, go to the R. You can't go to the ER and get chemotherapy for cancer. You can't go to the ER and get diabetes shots, you know, like that isn't the sustainable thing.
而治疗的现实是，保险公司通常偏好的快速修复方案，往往最终成本更高。你知道，人们去急诊室的最大原因，或者说慢性病的原因，往往是那些本可以预防的疾病。你知道，那些只会说“好吧，没人会阻止你去急诊室，去吧”的人，你不能去急诊室做癌症化疗，你不能去急诊室打糖尿病针，你知道，那不是可持续的。
We need kind of a preventative mechanism. So those patchwork solutions are this systemic problem, but the fundamental issue remains. We've created a health care system that knows the price of everything, and it doesn't value anything that most people have to actually encounter when they get health care. So we've engineered this system where the only way to survive is to stop acting like a healer and start acting like this factory, which psychiatrists have done. And a lot of them don't like that. But when you make an economic incentive, most people will follow an incentive structure.
我们需要一种预防机制。所以那些修补式的解决方案是系统性的问题，但根本问题依然存在。我们创造了一个了解万物价格，却不重视人们在获得医疗服务时真正需要的东西的医疗体系。所以我们设计了这个系统，唯一的生存方式就是停止扮演治愈者的角色，开始像工厂一样运作，精神科医生已经这样做了。他们很多人并不喜欢这样。但当你制造经济激励时，大多数人都会遵循激励结构。
And the people always email and they're like, well, I know a guy who didn't. Great. I'm talking about probability. I'm talking what do you want 90% of the industry to be doing, even if one percent of it is this awesome dude that you know, that you emailed me about. You know, the hands are kind of tied here. And I don't really have a solution than going back to the drawing board about how it's structured. Because I don't think there's any, this is studying our powerlessness against that system. But here's the reason why this relates to that whole thing that I'm talking.
人们总是发邮件说，好吧，我认识一个人没这样做。太好了。我说的是概率。我说的是你希望行业中90%的人在做什么，即使你发邮件告诉我的那个很棒的家伙只占1%。你知道，这里的手势有点被束缚了。除了回到原点重新思考它的结构，我真的没有解决办法。因为我不认为有什么……这只是在研究我们对该系统的无力感。但这就是为什么这与我所谈论的有关。
about with the DSM loosely is that these power structures are very interrelated, right? And remember that psychiatry wasn't saved by changing the DSM. They kept thinking that eventually this new direction of checklist will pay dividends and make us taken seriously and make diagnoses relatively consistent among doctors. Since they're using a checklist, all the patients will go in. They're getting the same checklist from different doctors, so different doctors will result in the same diagnosis. That hasn't happened.
关于DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）的那些事，这些权力结构是高度相互关联的，对吧？记住，精神病学并没有通过修改DSM而得到拯救。他们一直认为，这种新的清单方向最终会带来红利，让我们被认真对待，并使医生之间的诊断相对一致。既然他们使用清单，所有的病人都会进去。他们从不同的医生那里得到相同的清单，所以不同的医生会得出相同的诊断。这并没有发生。
The three, the four, and the five versions of the DSM, or attempts to go in this direction where it would have validity, and it doesn't. It's still just like these hunches of like whatever they think about you. And part of that isn't because it may not even be because checklists don't work. I don't really like the checklist of the DSM3, but they might work if you gave people an hour. It's pretty hard when you're trying to cram five-minute visits into your 15-minute billing code, but you don't get penalized for not taking that amount of time. I mean, the other thing that I don't understand is if you say that you did an hour of foot surgery,
DSM的第三、第四和第五版，都是试图朝着这个方向发展以获得有效性，但并没有。它仍然只是基于他们对你想法的某种直觉。部分原因甚至可能不是因为清单不起作用。我不太喜欢DSM-3的清单，但如果你给人们一个小时的时间，它们可能会起作用。当你试图把五分钟的问诊塞进15分钟的计费代码里时，这很难，而且如果你没有花那么多时间，也不会受到惩罚。我的意思是，我不明白的另一件事是，如果你说你做了长达一小时的足部手术，
I mean, I guess maybe you finish early and you don't want to just sit there and look at the patient. You want to get them up. So I kind of get it that, you know, what they're doing is different. So if it's over, why make them just like wait before they do the next one or something? But like if I can just be like, wow, you had a breakthrough. 20 minutes. You're good. I'm not able to do that.
我的意思是，我想也许你提前完成了，你不想只是坐在那里看着病人。你想让他们起来。所以我有点明白，你知道，他们做的事情是不一样的。所以如果结束了，为什么要让他们在做下一个之前等待呢？但如果我能说，哇，你取得了突破。20分钟。你好了。我做不到这一点。
Maybe all of these codes should relate to time, you know, and then the cost of the education. But you should sort of be capped on your time. Like you shouldn't be able to cram five people into an hour. If you didn't do it for 15 minutes, you can't use the code. If I don't do therapy for 53 minutes, I can't say 90837. You know, why can you use your CPT code if you're not spending that amount of time there? But this is a gilded cage that psychiatry has trapped itself in. Because remember in that DSM article, it was the schizophrenia epidemic, not the changes of the DSM
也许所有的这些代码都应该与时间有关，你知道，还有教育成本。但你的时间应该受到限制。你不应该能把五个人塞进一个小时里。如果你没有做满15分钟，你就不能使用该代码。如果我没有进行53分钟的治疗，我就不能说90837。你知道，如果你没有花那么多时间，为什么可以使用你的CPT代码？但这正是精神病学为自己建造的镀金牢笼。因为记住在那篇关于DSM的文章中，是精神分裂症的流行，而不是DSM的变化，
that brought back some validity to psychiatry. In the 90s, you know, the one psychiatrist who's on this rock is sitting there going, what can we do that nobody else can? We can prescribe psychiatric medication. A cardiologist isn't really trained at doing that. An LPC and a social worker can't. They were like, what makes us as psychiatrists with an MD better than social workers and LPCs?
才让精神病学恢复了一些有效性。在90年代，你知道，这个领域里的一位精神科医生坐在那里想，我们能做什么别人做不到的？我们可以开精神科药物。心脏病专家并没有真正受过这方面的训练。LPC（持证专业咨询师）和社会工作者不能。他们当时想，作为拥有医学博士学位的精神科医生，是什么让我们比社会工作者和LPC更好？
And a lot of the through line in this argument is that when you make the industry split, like we're now splitting between clinical research and academic practice, it's a bad thing. And when you pit people against each other doing the same job, that's all so bad, right? Like that's the point of a union. So you're not competing with Bob. You're working with Bob in order to get something.
这个论点中的许多主线是，当你让行业分裂时，比如我们现在在临床研究和学术实践之间分裂，这是一件坏事。当你让做同样工作的人互相竞争时，这也是坏事，对吧？这就是工会的意义所在。所以你不是在和鲍勃竞争。你是在和鲍勃合作以获得某些东西。
And this RUC put psychiatry in competition with me in 1980. And then by the 90s, when the Ruck is happening, they say, you know, in 92, we can prescribe medication. They can't. We're worth more. And I mean, I get it. You got loans. But generally, you want competition to be in markets, not amongst specialists. because when it's amongst the communication of an academic sector that's supposed to be working together and speaking the same language, you don't want those people fighting. It's bad for everybody. So the result was just kind of catastrophic when they said, hey, you know, schizophrenia saves it and these early antipsychotics save it. You know, we don't really have the Prozac revolution and stuff until a little bit later in the 90s where that stuff becomes, you know, something that everybody knows about. We don't really have ADHD yet. So there's this change.
而这个RUC在1980年让精神病学与我形成了竞争。然后到了90年代，当RUC发生时，他们在92年说，我们可以开药。他们不能。我们更值钱。我的意思是，我明白。你有贷款。但通常情况下，你希望竞争存在于市场中，而不是专家之间。因为当它存在于本应合作并使用相同语言的学术部门的交流中时，你不希望这些人打架。这对每个人都不好。所以当他们说，嘿，你知道，精神分裂症拯救了它，这些早期的抗精神病药物拯救了它，结果是灾难性的。你知道，我们直到90年代后期才真正有了百忧解革命之类的东西，那时这些东西才成为每个人都知道的事情。我们还没有真正出现多动症。所以有这种变化。
chilling effect that freezes the profession, and even the psychiatrist who wanted to do therapy, who believed in it, who were trained in it, had maybe been in therapy themselves once or twice, couldn't afford to do it. And this invisible hand of the ruck pushed them towards a 15-minute med check that might actually take five minutes. And this is why the checklist model of the DSM became not just an intellectual preference, but an economic survival strategy. If you have 15 minutes with a patient, you can't do a dynamic formulation. So thank God that you got this checklist from the DSM-3, because you can just run down a list of symptoms and say that they check those boxes, and nobody can say that you're incompetent.
这种寒蝉效应冻结了整个行业，甚至那些想做治疗、相信治疗、受过治疗训练、甚至自己可能做过一两次治疗的精神科医生，也负担不起。而RUC这只看不见的手将他们推向了可能只需要五分钟的15分钟药物检查。这就是为什么DSM的清单模式不仅成为一种智力偏好，而且成为一种经济生存策略。如果你有15分钟的时间面对病人，你无法进行动态构思。所以感谢上帝，你从DSM-3得到了这个清单，因为你可以直接列出一系列症状，说他们勾选了这些框，没有人能说你无能。
Nobody can say that you did anything wrong. And then you write a prescription. So the RUC and the DSM coming together did have this, and it wasn't intentional. There wasn't like one guy that did this. I don't have, you know, the Godfather complex where I think every bad thing is controlled by one thing. Sometimes bad things just sort of happen on accident or independently. And what happened here is that psychiatry built a gilded cage for themselves.
没有人能说你做错了什么。然后你写一张处方。所以RUC和DSM结合在一起确实产生了这种影响，而且这不是故意的。并没有一个人做了这件事。我没有，你知道，教父情结，认为每一件坏事都由一件事控制。有时坏事只是偶然或独立发生的。这里发生的事情是，精神病学为自己建造了一个镀金的牢笼。
where yeah, on average they get $240,000, but they can't get out of it and they can't do what they want and they can't talk to the people who maybe know a little bit more about the way that these forces work or how therapy works or the patient and that's bad. So I usually try and offer some kind of solution. I don't have one here. I think that we need to know the history. We need to know the forces. We need to know these things.
在那里，平均收入是24万美元，但他们无法摆脱它，他们无法做他们想做的事，他们无法与那些可能更了解这些力量如何运作，或者治疗如何运作，或者病人情况的人交谈，这很糟糕。所以我通常会尝试提供某种解决方案。我这里没有。我认为我们需要了解历史。我们需要了解这些力量。我们需要了解这些事情。
We don't just need to say, well, that's capitalism for you. or like, yo, psychofarmacudoc companies do that, yuck, yuck. Or even the people that say that the DSM is just this system of systematic control that's designed to put people in boxes and control society and keep, you know, beautiful artists like me away from the normies that whatever. Maybe that was the result of it. It was not the initial intention. And it definitely isn't making anyone wealthy.
我们不能只是说，好吧，这就是资本主义。或者说，哟，精神药物公司这样做，真恶心。甚至那些说DSM只是这种旨在将人放入盒子里、控制社会、让像我这样美丽的艺术家远离普通人的系统性控制系统的人……也许那是结果。这并不是最初的意图。而且它绝对没有让任何人变得富有。
If you want to analyze these systems, look where money goes. And then look at why they're there and then decide if it's a good thing. and when somebody says something about it, you're able to explain to them how these things work. And a lot of therapists don't. I mean, the fact that doctors are emailing me saying that a publicly traded, a public, you know, entity disclosing its relationship to this private one that has a website and tells you exactly what it does and sort of runs our industry,
如果你想分析这些系统，看看钱去了哪里。然后看看它们为什么在那里，然后决定这是否是一件好事。当有人对此发表意见时，你能够向他们解释这些事情是如何运作的。而很多治疗师却做不到。我的意思是，医生们给我发邮件说，一个上市公司，一个披露其与这个拥有网站并确切告诉你它做什么、并运行我们行业的私营实体之间关系的实体，
they think that is a conspiracy theory that I made up because I'm a social worker and they're a doctor? That's weird. That's pretty lowest common denominator. reductive argumentation. If you really want to make a case for why these things are bad, you need to know how they work. And if you know how they work, you're probably going to decide that they're bad. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们认为这是我因为是社会工作者而他们是医生而编造的阴谋论？这很奇怪。这是最低级的还原论论证。如果你真的想证明为什么这些事情很糟糕，你需要知道它们是如何运作的。如果你知道它们是如何运作的，你很可能会认为它们很糟糕。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。